hi my name is Luke Siciliano I'm a web
developer
so self-employed I've decided to do this
video for free code camp on the topic of
how you can make money as a freelance
developer or as someone who has just
started up their own independent
development business I feel that this is
an important topic to talk about because
a lot of people learn to code and then
strike out on their own and quickly
realize that running a business is a
whole lot different than learning the
code or working a dev job somewhere so
the goal of this video is really to
provide some tips and some framework for
those who have decided to strike out on
their own hopefully make the whole
venture a little bit more enjoyable and
B and most importantly a little bit more
if not a lot more profitable so in this
video we're really going to talk about a
few different things number one is we're
gonna lay out some basic rules for
making money as an independent developer
and you may think well making money as
easy I do work for people and I make
money well some developers make a lot
more money than others and the things
we're going to focus on in that segment
will touch on why and how you can
actually increase your profits and make
more money as a developer the second
thing we're going to talk about is
planning your new business and what I
mean by this is the fact that you don't
want to just run out and you know hang
up your sign and say woohoo I'm in
business now you really need to have a
plan in place that deals with things
such as what type of customers are you
going to serve what types of services
are you going to offer and you know what
kind of company are you going to form
and so on so forth if you have all those
things nailed it from the get-go
then you wind up making a lot more money
and having a lot less stress on the back
end so that's the second thing we'll be
talking about the third thing we'll be
talking about is actually getting
started and at that point you've made
your plan you've decided who you're
gonna serve what services you're gonna
offer and all that good stuff but now
you've actually got to form the business
you've got to get your infrastructure in
place and all those things and that's
what we'll be dealing with in that part
of the video and in the fourth segment
of this video we'll talk about managing
your business on a day to day basis from
both an administrative standpoint as
well as a development standpoint and
you're going to find that doing both are
equally important and if you manage
yourself on a day-to-day
Mace's correctly you can really make a
lot more money so before we dive into it
let's talk about who this video is for
if you're someone who has already
decided I'm going to go the freelance
route I'm gonna start an independent
development shop or you've already done
that you know in other words you're
already on your own somewhere then this
video is for you if you are debating
whether or not you want to be a
freelance developer whether or not you
want to start your own dev shop or just
kind of debating whether you want to get
a job for somebody and that's the topic
I've already discussed in a prior video
and we're gonna link to that in the
description below with a timestamp so I
would suggest watching that portion of
that video before deciding whether or
not you know this video is appropriate
for you so with all that said let's get
to it and good luck
okay so the first thing we're going to
talk about is the three basic rules to
making money as a three lance developer
and you've got to nail all three of
these things otherwise you're really
gonna find yourself feeling like you're
always stuck in second gear if not first
gear and you're gonna feel like you just
can't get ahead in your business and you
may very well quit right because what
happens when you feel like you're not
getting ahead you certainly don't want
to continue of something so
understanding the three rules to making
money as a freelancer is key before we
get into anything else so what are the
three rules number one is understanding
that the amount of money you're going to
make is in direct proportion to the
amount of value you provide to other
people so in other words you other
person provide value okay
that's rule number one rule number two
is understanding the need to focus on
your highest paying activities which may
sound like duh but you would be
surprised at how many people struggle in
that area and rule number three is the
need to understand that you have a
full-time job and put in the time as
soon as you strike out on your own again
may sound common sense but you would be
surprised so let's go ahead and take a
look at each of these three rules
alright and again you have to do all
three number one the amount of money
you're going to make is in direct
proportion to the amount of value you
provide to other people what do I mean
by this and first thing I do is put
yourself in the shoes of a customer
alright the customer doesn't care about
your experience the customer doesn't
care about you know what languages you
know they don't care about how much time
you're gonna put into something all that
matters to them is the amount of value
their business receives from the product
you provide to them right let's say for
example you're building an app for let's
say a little restaurant and you know the
restaurant owner says hey I want an app
where people can order food online I
want an app where people can make
reservations online see my menu things
of this nature somebody comes along and
offers to build this app in a content
management system like WordPress or
Joomla or something like that
they tell the restaurant when they'll do
it for 3,000 bucks you come along and
you tell the restaurant owner that
you'll build them something from scratch
you'll write your own HTML you'll write
your own CSS you'll write your own
JavaScript and you're gonna charge them
$5,000 well here if your $5,000 app is
right here and someone else is $3,000
CMS bait paste app is right here and you
provide no more functionality and no
more value to the client in other words
you don't make the clients business any
better with your apps and this person
does what's their app then all that all
you've done is proposed something it's
more expensive right if you're not
providing additional value to your
customer they're not gonna pay more
money okay why would I pay 5,000 for
something I can get the exact same
functionality for 3,000 so which you've
got to understand is the more you
improve the customer's situation the
more money that customer is going to be
willing to pay you okay so in other
words it's not about what you think is
important it's about what the customer
sees as value so instead of saying
mine's better because I'm not using a
CMS and I'm writing it I'm writing all
the code myself again that doesn't make
the customer situation any better right
but I hear from developers all the time
and I've had many conversations with
freelance developers who really do think
that simply by coding things from
scratch instead of using you know
different tools that they're somehow
providing a better product wait well
these are people who don't understand
it's about providing value to the
customer so if you're gonna write
something from scratch for the customer
what you need to do is explain how your
app provides value that the other one
doesn't so for example and that person's
building you an app in a content
management system here are some of the
limitations in the content management
system it may limit you in terms of how
you want to grow your business with the
app I'm gonna write for you however you
won't have those limitations and then
you explain to them about how your app
provides additional value that the other
one does in other words value meaning
your app allows their business to grow
more than the other app
okay so taking the approach of
understanding that you've got to explain
value to your customers is how you're
gonna make more money always put
yourself in your customers perspective
and ask yourself what is that the
customer is looking for what does the
customer see as valuable the more you
provide that value to the customer the
more the customers going to be willing
to pay you okay that's rule number one
provide value to the customer rule
number two is the fact that you need to
focus on your highest paying activities
way too often and I mean way too often
people get themselves in this trap of
focusing on work that has the highest
total price tag but doesn't necessarily
pay the most per unit of input let's use
a simple example let's say I'm gonna
write a dinky little app for somebody
pretty simple it's only gonna take me
maybe five hours I'm gonna charge them
2,500 bucks for it let's say that's five
hundred dollars an hour right now let's
say it's also only twenty five hundred
dollars now let's say the opportunity to
write another app comes along and on
that app I'm gonna charge fifty thousand
dollars but I have to put in a lot and I
mean a lot more time for obvious reasons
on that big app well the first app you
know let's say I made twenty five
hundred and five hours okay it's five
hundred an hour second app let's say
when i sat sit down and look at it later
I realized I only made 350 an hour on it
a lot of people will get in the trap of
saying well you know I made more money
over here because I made twenty five
thousand dollars as opposed to 2,500 but
what they're not recognizing is that you
only have so much time in a day you only
have so many resources to go around and
you need to put those resources into the
higher value activities so one was just
enough the higher dollar amount in that
scenario was just a chance to work more
basically so what you want to do is look
at the kinds of services you're
providing and let's say you're providing
three different services for different
services to customers whatever your
service you're providing pick the one
that pays the most per hour of
per resource that you put into it and do
more of that so using my scenario from a
minute ago the $2,500 app you can get
done in five hours go out and find as
many customers as you can to turn those
apps out forget that larger work just
try to turn those other things out in
mass because again you make more per
unit of input on those think of it in
these terms if you have a choice of
going to a job that pays you $10 an hour
and you can work all the hours you want
you have a choice of going to another
job that pays you $15 an hour and you
can work all the hours you want I would
hope you would go to $15 an hour job all
the time and never show up at the $10 an
hour job again right I mean that's only
common sense so you've got to take this
same approach into your freelance
business whatever is paying you the most
focus on that and do as much of that as
you humanly can we're going to talk a
little bit more about this and a little
bit later section in this course but for
right now understand that the second
rule of making money is focusing on the
activities that pay you the most per
unit of input your highest value
activities okay so rule number one
provide value to the customer rule
number two
is focused on the activities that are
the highest value to your freelancing
business rule number three is you've got
to put in the time again that may sound
simple but you would be really surprised
once you decide to go out on your own
you have a full-time job
you need to work full-time at your
business this may sound like a sound
like a shock but you don't get paid for
not going to work okay
so let's say you've got two customers
you're just starting out and right now
those two customers keep you busy for
say 15 hours a week a lot of developers
are gonna do that 15 hours of coding
work and you know customer service every
week and then after that just kind of
sit around twiddling our thumbs you know
wait for more work to come in the door
but again what they don't understand is
like I said once you strike out on your
own you have a full time job so let's
just say you call a full time job 40
hours a week
well if you
customers are only taking up 15 hours a
week that means you have 25 more hours
that you need to be out trying to house
a lot more business so 15 hours working
for customers 25 hours trying to hustle
up more business equals your 40 hours
and think of how many couple more
customers you'll have if you put in that
time in other words there is something
you can be doing on you know to fill up
your hours and make it a full-time job
treat your business like a full-time job
you're not going to make any money
unless you work at it and as silly as
that may sound again you would be
surprised I I've talked to a small
business owner after small business
owner after a small business owner who
doesn't work 40 hours a week a lot of
times they don't work 30 hours a week
and they're wondering why they're not
making any money well you don't make
money for not working okay
so rule number one focus on providing
value to your customer understand that
your customer only cares about the value
they receive and focus on providing as
much value to them as humanly possible
rule number two is identify the
activities in your business which pay
you the most per unit of input your
highest value activities to yourself and
focus on those rule number three is put
in the time if you follow those three
things you really are going to be ahead
of a very large percentage of other
freelance developers out there and I
mean a very large percentage of them you
are ahead of the game
from the get-go just by understanding
those three things okay and because
you're gonna understand those three
things that's why you're going to do
well working for yourself so now that
we've talked about the three basic rules
of making money let's talk about the
planning stage of your new business
okay let's go ahead and talk about the
planning stage of your new company and
what I mean by the planning stage is the
fact that these are tasks and plans you
should have in place before you even
start taking customers if you do already
have customers which is common freelance
businesses then before you go out and
try to bring in a whole lot more
business you should really be knocking
out the things we're about to talk about
the reason why I say it's common for
people already have customers before
they've planned out their business is a
lot of times people start freelancing as
a result of getting a random phone call
and someone asking to complete a project
and then BAM next thing you know you're
a freelancer so wherever you're at in
your business whether you've already got
your first customer - or whether you're
decided to strike out on your own and
have not done so yet the following tasks
that we're about to talk about are
things that you need to get planned and
in order before you start trying to take
customers at any kind of scale okay so
we're really going to talk about four
total things excuse me when it comes to
planning your business number one is
funding your operations you may be
thinking well what funding we'll talk
about that in a minute
number two is deciding what nish you're
going to serve in other words you're not
just going to provide random services to
as many people as possible you want to
actually pick a niche that you're gonna
serve and stay within that Lane number
three is figuring out what services
you're going to offer within that niche
and number four is going ahead and
getting your company formed once you've
got all those things figured out so
let's go ahead and look at each of these
things in turn
okay so the first thing we need to talk
about is how you're gonna find your new
business and right now when you hear
that you might be thinking what funding
is involved is a freelancer all I need
to write code is my laptop and I already
have that you will quickly be surprised
at how fast expenses do start to add up
for even someone who's self-employed
you're going to have different service
costs those service costs can include
paying an accountant at the end of the
year they can include paying for
liability insurance for your business
they can include the cost of a payroll
company because you're gonna want to
form what's called an S corp which we'll
talk about a little later also if your
rent server space you're going to that's
the service you're gonna pay for in
other words expenses will add up a lot
faster than you may think
and the one thing I cannot stress enough
is that you want to be profitable from
day one in your business and profitable
every essentially every month after day
one and month one it's really common in
the technology industry for people to
think it's okay to lose money for the
sake of growth that is not okay it is
not okay I know there are some big
companies that have operated that way
but trust me that is the exception it is
not the rule contrary to what you see in
the media what I would strongly suggest
is for that you read a book called
profit first we're going to link to it
in the description below it talks a lot
about why it is not okay for you to be
ever be losing money so in other words
you want to be profitable from day one
and you want to never be unprofitable
okay so since you need to be profitable
from day one the first manner of
business is figuring out how to fund
your operations do not go into debt to
start your business okay
Mark Cuban is on record is saying that
only idiots would take on a loan or
worse yet use a credit card to start a
business if you take out a loan
trust me the bank doesn't care if you
are make
money or not you've got to make those
payments if you borrow money from
relatives if you want to you know not
paying your relatives back might be a
good way to destroy your relationship
with them and if you start using credit
cards next thing you know you're paying
extremely high interest rates so do not
go into debt it's essentially digging
yourself into a hole that can be very
difficult to get out of if you're
someone that's just starting out and
you've already got your first customer
then whatever they're paying you
essentially needs to sit in your
business bank account and not go into
your pocket it needs to sit in your
business bank account and serve as a
source of funding for when you get your
next client if you don't have your first
client yet and you're striking out on
your own
then as we talked about in our last
section you need to be working 40 hours
a week at your new business but you also
need to be making some other money on
the side to support yourself so whether
that's through some kind of side
household whether it's driving for uber
or whatever you need to be self-funding
in this in other words your business
needs to fund itself and if you're just
starting out then you need to fund your
new business from whatever your other
form of employment or income is in other
words be self funding and profitable
from day one do not take out debt do not
take out loans this is something I
cannot stress enough so best ways to
fund your new business there are quite a
few like I said if you have a full-time
job and you've decided to go the
freelance route then guess what you now
have two full-time jobs stay at your
current job while working full time at
your freelance gig until you're in a
spot where you can quit the full-time
job which if you're hustling up at the
freelance gig and working full-time at
it you will be able to quit your
full-time job pretty quickly okay so
your current source of your current
employment can be a form of funding if
you've got your first client again what
they pay you should just sit in the
operating account there's funding for
your business don't take it out and
spend it leave it in there to fund the
business
if you don't have a job currently and
you are striking out on your own as a
freelancer and you don't have any
clients then again what you need to be
doing is driving for uber or finding
other ways to make money and live off of
that and live off of that and leave some
in the you know in your reserves so you
can also find your business going
forward
but find your business with cash that
you have in cash that you earn do not
fund it with debt that is something I
cannot stress enough one of the best
ways to make sure your freelance
business fails is to start taking on
debt okay and just think of it like this
it's pretty hard to go broke if you
don't know anybody any money right when
you think of people who go broke it's
usually because of that avoid debt in
your new business I can't stress this
enough this is something I'm not gonna
go on and on about instead again read
profit first it's linked to in the
description below ok so since we've
talked about the biggest rule of funding
your business avoid debt and fund it
from other sources let's go ahead and
talk about picking a niche for your new
business
okay so let's talk about choosing an ish
for your new freelance business and what
do I mean by nish by nish I mean you
need to select a relatively narrow group
of customers you're going to serve
and/or a relatively narrow group of
services you're going to provide you do
not want to take the approach of saying
I need work I will take whatever is
available and whatever comes in my door
picking an ish is this strategy for
making more money taking whatever comes
in the door is a strategy for making
less money so let's look at two things
number one let's figure out why it is
you need an ish in the first place and
number two let's go about how you pick
that niche okay
so number one why do you need an ish in
the first place well as I just said a
second ago it leads to you having a less
scalable business let's use a really
simple example suppose I owned a
restaurant and I come to you and I say
hey I want you to build me an app that
for my restaurant that does a B and C
okay to get that app working you may
have to incorporate some third-party
applications into it which means you
have to go out and research those
third-party applications you have to
figure out what you need to do to
incorporate them in the app when you
build it and so on and so forth you also
might not know anything about the
restaurant industry and as a result of
that you need to take the time to learn
a lot about the industry in general so
you can learn about my business build me
a quality app and you charge me $5,000
from my app now later when the second
restaurant comes along and wants a
similar app you're already familiar with
those third-party applications you
already know a little bit about the
restaurant industry that is all learning
that you do not have to do a second time
in order to charge the same amount of
money the second time when you're
building that second application so in
other words by staying within the niche
under this example restaurants you make
more money and less or you make more
money by providing the same service in
less time right to the second customer
that's what happens when you choose a
niche you're not in a state where you're
constantly learning new languages
learning new applications learning new
industries and so on so forth the value
of experience allows you to scale up
your business and make more money by
the same rate for your services but
getting things done in less time okay
what happens when you don't pick an ish
well then you're constantly learning new
languages you're constantly dealing with
different kinds of businesses you're
less likely to be able to reuse old code
bases that you've written and so on so
forth
so picking an ish allows you to build a
scalable business I cannot stress that
enough now it is really really easy when
you're first starting out to say I'm
gonna take whatever comes in the door
right because after all you're just
starting out you need clients let's look
at what that leads to you take whatever
comes in the door as I said a minute ago
you have to maybe learn any language you
have learned some new frameworks you
have to learn new applications you have
to learn about a new industry and as a
result you make some money but you don't
make as much as you could the second
time around
right and now when your second client
comes in the door the problem is because
you're just taking anything and not
sticking in a niche your second client
is in an industry or field that has
nothing to do with the first one so
again you've a learn some new
applications and learn some new
frameworks so on so forth you're
constantly in a state of working more
hours for less money and as a result of
that you never get ahead and because you
never get ahead you find yourself saying
I need work so I'm gonna take whatever
comes in the door and it just becomes a
vicious cycle that you literally never
get out of so while it may be tempting
to say I'm gonna come whatever or I'm
gonna take whatever comes in the door I
should say because I need money right
now you have to recognize that that is a
trap and it becomes very difficult to
get out of taking work simply because
it's available when it's outside of an
issue want to serve is like stepping
over a dollar to pick up a dime it is
not a good idea step over a dollar and
pick up a dime so we get those work
opportunities early on that are outside
of the NISS you're trying to serve it's
hard but it's important to say no and
trust me I completely understand it is
hard to say no to revenue it is hard to
say no to a potential customer but if
it's outside that nish you want to serve
whether that niche is working with a
particular class a customer or providing
a particular type of service or a
combination of both it's important to
say no when something falls outside your
niche I just cannot stress
enough picking an ish means a more
scalable business so how do you go about
picking that nish right that's a that's
an important question that's really a
broad topic and which could probably be
I would say the subject of a second
extremely long video the general rules
I'll give you for picking in nish are
pick something that you either are
either one of two things one interested
in it or two passionate / you get
excited about it you know or you're good
at it my guess would be a third thing so
why do I say to pick something that you
are excited about passionate about
something your excuse me something
you're really good at or something you
have a particular skill set at number
one is the fact that those are going to
be things that you're likely to stick
out the grind through right think of it
like this if you're trying to do
something that you're not good at and
you're not excited about start in your
in those hard days of starting a
business where the chances you're gonna
stick with this thing that you're not
any good at it
not excited about when you're already
facing the struggles starting a business
the chances of you sticking with that
aren't very good right so by picking
something that you're either good at or
excited about the chances are you're
gonna stick it out you know through the
grind a lot more number two is the fact
that if you're picking something that
you're already good at and passionate
about you're gonna find that that gives
you the ability to provide more value
than your competitors in that area so
you're gonna have a competitive
advantage in large part because you are
willing to put in that time so
willingness to stick it out competitive
advantage or the two big reasons why
when choosing in this you need to pick
something that you're good at something
that you're passionate about something
that just kind of gets you excited so on
so forth the things I mentioned one
interesting question I would say I get a
lot is well how do I pick a niche and
then I say what I just said I say well
what are you excited about what do you
like to do what are you good at and
people didn't look at me a little bit
confused and just to be frank the
question of what do you like to do
shouldn't be a hard question I mean what
is it you like to do right
you know find things you aren't
interested in personally and then try to
make those your business and then that's
something you're going to be more likely
to stick with over time don't over
complicate the idea of finding something
that interests you and it is kind of
rolling with it I cannot stress that
enough so number one pick an ish number
two is when you're picking that niche
find something you're interested in
something you're excited about you know
so on something you enjoy so on and so
forth okay so now that that's out of the
way let's go on the next part of our
video
okay now that you've decided what nish
you're going to serve it's important to
figure out what services you're going to
offer to that niche and then how you're
going to charge for those services so
let's look at each of those and we're
really going to break this part of the
discussion down into three sections
the first section is going to be what
services to offer the second section is
going to be how to charge for those
services and then the third part is
going to be the need to make sure you're
adding recurring revenue okay so let's
look at each of these in turn number one
what services should you be offering
your potential customers that are within
and this you've picked out for yourself
well what services to offer really comes
down to three things and the first of
these three things is how much are you
interested in to work the second of
these three things is to what extent is
it scalable the third of these three
things is to what extent can you
outsource some of the work those three
things decide what services you should
be offering your niche let's look at
each of those the reason why your level
of interest is important when you're
deciding what services you're going to
offer is simple if you're performing
work that you find boring that you find
all that you don't care about whatsoever
the chances of you wanting to stick with
it long term and build a business are
slim to none - if there was a way to say
negative it would probably be negative
think of it like this if you have a
nine-to-five job you certainly don't
want to go to something that's
completely boring every day right well
trying to do that in the grind of your
own business is even harder so when
deciding what services to offer it needs
to be something that interests you
number one even if something interests
you though to have a viable business it
needs to be something you can scale out
in other words something you can do at
scale and the scalability of your idea
really has two components to it
number one is the fact of is or is the
question of is there enough of a
customer base out there you may perform
a task for somebody and really enjoy the
work and then find out it's just
something that doesn't come up that much
if there's not enough of a market out
there that's not something you're going
to be able to do at scale but the other
aspect of scalability is
the extent to which you can do the work
without having to completely do
everything over each time so in other
words if you want to build a particular
type of app for somebody and you realize
it's a codebase you can reuse and build
similar apps for a large number of other
people that's scalable because you're
reusing that codebase for similar
customers over and over and over again
so in other words you make more money
off the second customer then you make
off the first customer you make more
money off the tenth customer than you
make off the second one because you're
refining this process every time because
you're charging the same amount of money
for the app each time right so
scalability which again is size of the
market and your ability to not have to
replicate or to not have to start work
over every time those are really how you
look at the scalability aspect of this
okay and number three in there again
when deciding what services to offer is
to what extent can you outsource some of
this work even if you work 24/7 365
there are only so many hours in the day
which means you can only take on so many
customers if you want to make money as a
freelancer and eventually scale up into
a larger business you're gonna have to
get some of the work off of your plate
so you can continue focusing on
high-value activities so when you're
putting together a service that you're
gonna offer you need to say how much of
this work can be performed by people
that maybe have like entry-level coding
skills how much of it can you outsource
for you know like a decent price to
other developers and so on so forth if
for some reason you look at your service
offering and realize it just cannot be
outsourced in any way or that there
aren't even components of it that can be
outsourced that's probably not a good
service offering to get into if you have
something you're interested in if you
have something you can scale and you
have something where at least a good
chunk of the work can be outsourced at a
later time now you have something that a
you can make a lot of money off of and
be eventually scale into a larger
business and that's why you're gonna do
that three part analysis and deciding
what services to offer within your niche
and
not snot too repetitive but that
three-part analysis is your level of
interest the extent to which you can
scale it out and the extent to which you
can outsource some of this work so
that's how you decide what you're going
to offer once you've decided what you're
going to offer it's important to look at
how you're going to charge for it and I
cannot stress enough it's important to
charge flat fees or charges set price
for products as opposed to charging say
by the hour charging by the hour would
be you know telling someone you'll build
them an app and you'll charge them X
number of dollars per hour and at the
end of the day you know you give them a
bill and again the problem with this is
the fact that there are only so many
hours in a day your trading time for
money which is always a losing
proposition by charging flat fees you
get to take advantage of the work you
have already done so for example if you
build an app that serves a particular
type of business you charge the business
$3,000 for that app and then later on a
second similar business comes along and
wants a similar app you've already done
a good amount of the work okay so you
can reuse a lot of that codebase and
then charge $3,000 for an app the second
time and the customer the second
customers should say is still getting
full value even though you're charging
them $3,000 because they're getting the
value of your expertise you became an
expert in this area the first time you
built the app they're getting the fact
that you would have already worked any
bugs out of the app because you probably
debugged it as part of dealing with the
first customer and so on so forth so by
charging flat fees you wouldn't you make
more per unit of your own input and you
actually give better value to the
customer so it's good for both sides you
make more profits the customer gets a
better experience and then the last
thing I'll say when it comes to choosing
what to offer pricing that offer is
third thing would be the need to add
recurring revenue and this is revenue
where you don't necessarily have to make
a brand new sale every month in order to
bring in some income into your business
in one of our businesses for
sample we have virtual private servers
and then we offer the clients the option
to have us host their app on our servers
which we do it in so we essentially
resell server space and then the clients
play pay a flat fee for that every month
so on top of the fact that we just have
money coming in every month for new
sales to new customers there's a certain
aspect that we can just count on coming
in every month you know again for that
recurring reselling revenue having
recurring revenue really helps to kind
of take out some of the highs and lows
of working for yourself otherwise you
might have months where you make a whole
lot and months where you make a little
having that recurring revenue really
gives you some flexibility to let you
kind of go along with your business ok
so we've just talked about what services
to offer how much to charge and we've
talked about the need for recurring
revenue so with all of that said let's
go on in the next part of our video
okay now that we've talked about what
services you're going to offer and how
you're going to charge for those
services we need to talk about actually
forming your business and this is going
to be the last part of our discussion in
the planning stages of starting your own
freelance enterprise okay so forming
your business really takes on a couple
of different things number one is
choosing the type of business entity
you're going to use for your company
and number two is actually getting it
formed here's the one thing I want to
stress before I get into these is this
video should not be considered legal
advice
I'm not holding myself out as someone
licensed to give you advice in forming a
company on legal consequences and things
of that sort
those are things that should really be
discussed with an attorney I cannot
stress that enough that there can be
serious consequences to choosing the
wrong for wrong form I should say for
your business so it's always good
discussed these kinds of matters with a
business lawyer when it comes to picking
a business entity it's not a matter of
just running out and starting to service
clients once you decide to become a
freelancer in most places you're going
to need some kind of a business license
okay working without that business
license can be a crime in some places
and usually is but also you want to
really start to think about forming a
company and in other words instead of
just going out and getting a business
license and working as a sole proprietor
there can be benefits to forming a
company such as a corporation or an LLC
which is a limited liability company
forming an S corp or forming some other
kind of corporate entity again the kind
of it that excuse me the kind of entity
you choose is going to depend on the
overall goals of your business and
that's why it's best to talk to a lawyer
what we do in our company is we've
chosen to operate as an LLC a limited
liability company the benefits of an LLC
are number one it is an actual separate
entity in other words it's considered a
separate legal entity from my partners
and I so what the LLC means is
that when our customers sign a contract
they don't sign it with us as
individuals they sign it with the LLC
they don't pay us as individuals they
pay the LLC when business expenses come
up they don't get paid by us personally
they get paid by the LLC the LLC has its
own bank account
and things of that nature if the if you
know we need a contract for services
like if we have to rent server space the
LLC signs the contract with somebody
else not you know we don't sign that as
individuals the many benefits of having
an LLC include protections from
liability so like let's say for example
we were to sign a long-term contract
with a vendor let's say we signed signed
up for server space and had to sign a
one-year commitment for that and let's
say after six months for whatever reason
our business fails and we don't want to
be in business anymore and the server
space vendor decides to try to take us
to collections or to even sue us to
collect the rest of the money they were
owed they could only sue the LLC they
could not sue us as individuals
generally speaking so in other words it
protects your individual credit your
individual assets and things of that
nature can also protect you under the
right circumstances from liability from
your clients so you know if a client
ever comes along and says hey you know I
hired Joe developer to do this software
work for me and he unrolled my app and
I'm suing them for damages well if their
contract is with an LLC generally
speaking they can sue the LLC and not in
the individual so having an LLC really
does provide you with liability
protection which can be really crucial
when you're going into business one of
the other big benefits of having out an
LLC which again is what we have is that
comes with several tax advantages namely
allows you to save on what would be
self-employment taxes that you would pay
if you're just working as a sole
proprietor the discussion on how having
an LLC can save you on self-employment
taxes it can be quite lengthy and I've
actually done a separate video on that
previously for free code camp we're
going to link to
video in the description below okay so
when you're trying to decide what to do
I would suggest watching that video but
again the first thing I would suggest
you do is talk to some kind of business
law attorney or corporate counsel on
what is the best fit for your particular
situation in your particular location to
meet your particular goals so the one
thing I want to stress in this is don't
just run out and start doing work figure
out what kind of entity it is you should
probably form and get that entity formed
before you go out and and get the
appropriate licenses before you go out
and start trying to hustle up work for
your new business so now that we've
talked about the need to form some kind
of business entity or at a minimum get
the appropriate licenses we're all done
talking about the planning stage for
your new business your new business is
officially planned - congratulations it
is now time to actually get started on
doing some work and making some money so
let's get to it
okay at this point of our video we've
just talked about the planning stages of
your business in other words you've
decided to become a freelance developer
and you've done all that initial
planning so you can have a business
that's gonna run well and run properly
and be well thought-out and you're not
just going to go out and try to open up
your own shop and haphazardly go about
your business in other words because
you've planned things out you're set up
for success now we need to talk about
some things you need to do initially to
actually get the doors open to your new
enterprise okay and those those areas
that you need to get knocked out first
are gonna really fall into two
categories one is administrative tasks
that you need to get set up and ready to
go before you start taking customers and
the second is marketing items that you
need to get set up and ready to roll
before you start taking customers and
the third thing I would say you need to
do on top of those is before you even
start taking a customers decide right
now you're going to be a continuous
learner and I'll talk about all three of
these in a minute and what I mean by
each of them but the one thing I want to
stress before we get into your checklist
and things to do when it comes to
starting your own business is the
importance of starting off on the right
foot okay in other words you need to
have all your administrative and
clerical and legal requirements met
before you start taking customers you
need to have a lot of your marketing
infrastructure in place before you go
out and start taking customers and you
also need to be just learning about new
things before you start taking customers
the reason I say especially when it
comes to your administrative and
marketing stuff that you need to have
these things organized and have all your
ducks in a row before you really start
trying to run your business
is because if you don't get these things
organized now then running your business
later is going to be much harder just
think of it like this you know you don't
get you don't get very well organized
when you start up shop as a result there
were documents you were supposed to file
with the IRS or the Secretary of State
that didn't get filed but then you just
started taking customer
right and then you're right in the
middle of a coding project and you get a
notice from the Secretary of State that
some items need to be taken care of
immediately otherwise you will no longer
be legally allowed to do business this
means you would have to stop your coding
project in the middle of what you're
doing to go deal with an administrative
headache that should have been dealt
with before
as a result your projects probably going
to be delayed to the client the clients
going to be unhappy you may have to give
them a partial discount if not a refund
and it's just gonna create a whole host
of headaches for you okay
so in other words by having all your
administrative tasks lined up completed
those initial tasks just done and
organized you helped avoid those fires
from popping up later that you then have
to stop what you're doing and put out
and by being organized in the beginning
you make more money later and the same
is true with your marketing if you've
got your marketing infrastructure in
place then you don't have to stop what
you're doing later in a mad panic to try
to drum up clients okay
so the one thing again I just cannot
stress enough is get your all your get
all your ducks in a row and get
organized before you even start taking
customers so again let's look at it from
an administrative standpoint a marketing
standpoint and then things you need to
be learning about on an ongoing basis
okay when starting your company there
going to be several essentially where I
call administrative tasks that you're
going to need to get taken care of and
out of the way and again as I stress in
the introduction of this section you
want to get these tasks taken care of
now so that they don't become problems
later so by getting all these things the
way you can actually focus on the
important thing which is doing dev work
okay so there's a few different things
you want to get out of the way up front
number one is you got to decide if
you're gonna form a company or work as a
sole proprietor I talked in a previous
section of this video about why we use
an LLC in our business talk with an
attorney or a lawyer you know get a
consultation with a business law lawyer
about whether you should form a
corporation whether you should form an
LLC you know whether you form some kind
of partnership in other words talk to an
attorney to see what's best for your
particular situation we use an LLC in
our business and I know a lot of times
that's what an attorney is going to
suggest to you but talk to a lawyer and
figure out what actually is the best
course for you given your particular
needs your particular circumstances the
laws and regulations of where you live
and so on and so forth
so number one is get your company formed
but after your company is formed it's
important to make sure that you're
keeping up with the business
requirements of wherever you live so for
example in Ohio where I live once you
form your company and you get your
business license you don't need to renew
your business license every year but
there are other states where you do need
to renew your business like license
every year in Nevada for example along
with renewing your business license
every year you have to file what's
called a list of officers every year so
the reason I'm telling you all this is
the to stress the importance of the fact
that the rules and regulations you have
to follow are going to be different
depending on where you live so it's
really important that you know the
regulations and rules of where you live
and you keep up with them and again
having a lawyer will help you do these
things if you don't keep up with those
regulations and you might lose your
ability to do business if you're you
know if you're in a place that you have
to renew your biz
licensed every year and you don't renew
it you may actually be committing a
crime by engaging in business without
having the appropriate licensing so in
addition to getting your company formed
make sure you're aware of your local
regulations and that you're keeping up
with them so number one is decide what
kind of entity you're going to form and
keep up with your local rules and
regulations
number two is to get a separate address
for your business generally speaking I
personally consider it a bad idea to use
your home address as your business
address there's no reason you can't but
that means for example putting your home
address on your company website that
means putting your home address on any
contracts you sign of clients that means
having business mail come to your house
so on so forth
for just personal peace of mind reasons
it can be a good idea to have a separate
address for your business and then also
if you're going to be forming a separate
entity like an LLC there may be other
benefits to having a separate address
and you'd want to talk about those
benefits with an attorney as well in
terms of where to have a separate
address lots of excuse me
lots of freelance developers will use
just a post office box and so a lot of
freelancers are working out of their
house if you're working at a shared
space such as a we work or Regis a lot
of times you can have that shared office
space and receive mail there so if
you're lookin sitting one of those kinds
of spaces ask them what kind of services
they offer in terms of you know using
their addresses your business address
receiving mail there and things of that
nature so post office box some kind of
shared office space there in other words
there are low-cost options for having a
separate mailing address for your
business third thing is to get a
separate bank account for your company
for this you'll need an ein from the IRS
as an employer identification number
you'll need that ein if you are starting
a separate entity such as an LLC or a
corporation or something like that
you want to have a separate bank account
for your business for a few reasons
number one if you're starting a separate
entity such as an LLC or a corporation
that entity is a separate you know
essentially a separate person from you
so your bank account needs to be kept
separate from that number two it helps
you keep your book straight in terms of
what's a personal expense and what's a
business expense number three having a
separate account for your business
allows you to stay a lot more
disciplined when it comes to budgeting
your business finances one of the
biggest reasons though for having a
separate bank account as the legal
reasons that an attorney will tell you
about you protect yourself in your
business by having a separate account
for your business and that is something
to talk about with a lawyer after you
started a bank account and you know
you've got your business address and all
that stuff
there are certain software software
services and just professional services
you want to sign up for you know for
your new business and that brings us to
the fourth thing on my list which is
software and services that you need to
sign up for the first of those is to get
some type of a business suite such as G
suite from Google or office 365 from
Microsoft these will make it much easier
for you to have a branded email so in
other words instead of you know instead
of your personal email or instead of new
developer at gmail.com you know you can
actually have an email on your own
domain which you don't have to have a
business suite like G suite and office
365 to do this obviously but it makes
managing your email easier and the big
benefit of those types of business
Suites as they include other services
such as calendaring cloud drive storage
and a few other things that are specific
to business ID they're relatively
inexpensive and I would strongly suggest
signing one of them up we use G suite in
our business and it makes our life a
whole lot easier you want to sign up for
your accounting software that is you
know how you're going to do your
bookkeeping there are a lot of options
here there's QuickBooks Online there's
Wave apps there's fresh books we
personally use wave in our business I
find it to be very
to use and the price is right because
it's free for you know for certain
services so again we use wave but that's
not what you have to use but definitely
you want to sign up for accounting
software you know so you can do your you
know so you can do your bookkeeping I
can't stress enough the importance of
regular bookkeeping and that's something
we'll talk about a little bit later in
this video the next thing you want to
sign up for is credit card processing
you know excitement Foursquare get
credit card processing through Intuit
wave who we do our accounting through
also offers credit card processing your
clients are gonna pay you with credit
card or if debit card the overwhelming
majority of the time and so a you want
to have something where you can send
them an online online invoice all the
services I just mentioned do that you
want them to be able to pay it online of
a credit card or a debit card one of the
reasons I say to get this set up now
even if you don't have a customer is
just think about it for a minute it's a
little bit awkward if client number one
calls you talk to you on the phone says
okay I want you to build my app you tell
them as three thousand dollars and they
say great send me an invoice and you
don't even have your software setup yet
to send them the invoice so in other
words get your software set up now and
your billing set up now and your credit
card processing all set up now and you
can send them the invoice right away it
doesn't take long to get this stuff
signed up so just get it done now there
is no reason to be doing it later when
you know when you need to send some to
the client just get out of the way and
sign up right now the next soft next
service I should say you're going to
want to sign up is a payroll service we
use the full service payroll offerings
from Intuit which is the parent company
of QuickBooks if you are starting an LLC
and S corp or an LLC to be taxed as an S
corp I should say or a corporation
you're going to need to pay yourself as
an employee and again the specifics of
that or something to talk about with a
lawyer but you are going to need to pay
yourself as an employee in addition to
taking distributions from the business
and once you start doing payroll as an
employee you'll find areas
just a lot of paperwork that's got to be
filed with the IRS get filed with the
state and your local governments and all
that fun stuff by having a payroll
service to do that for you you save a
massive amount of time we pay a fee
every month and to Intuit full service
payroll and they take care of all of our
paperwork for us I mean 100% of it and
it just makes our life so much easier it
is so worth the cost and it allows us to
stay in compliance in terms of
everything we need to be filing in terms
of payroll so there are other services
you're going to need to sign up for and
other software products you're going to
need to sign up for but the ones I would
stress immediately to make sure you're
ready to roll with are again your
business Suites this is G suite office
365 Zoho any of those companies that
have similar offerings excuse me your
accounting software we use wave but
again there's offerings such as
quickbooks online fresh books and
several others sign up for a credit card
processor such as with stripe wave
square into a creek into it credit card
processing any of those in the fourth
one on that list is get signed up for a
payroll service
I just cannot stress all those things
enough the next thing you're going to
want to do as part of your
administrative tasks getting going this
is the fourth thing on our list remember
first one was get your company in entity
form to know your licensing requirements
second one was get your business address
third one was get your bank accounts
setup fourth one I'm sorry so fourth one
was your software and services fifth
thing you're going to want to do is get
your contracts ready these are the
contracts you're going to send to
customers so in other words let's say
I'm your customer I call you I say I
want you to build an app for me
and in you give me a quote me three
thousand dollars I say great
send me over our contract so I can sign
it this is a form contract that you will
send me or a mostly form contract at
least that you would send me to for me
to sign agreeing that you're going to do
the work and what I'm going to pay you
and so on so forth
there are places you can get these types
of contracts such as LegalZoom there are
problems with just getting forms off the
internet though they may not be the
right call for your situation it is very
much worth the money to pay a small
business lawyer to look over some four
form contracts for you and give you some
feedback and help you make sure you're
on the right track in terms of the forms
you're sending off to potential clients
to sign so you know like I said you can
pull a form off of LegalZoom my strong
advice would be to talk to an attorney
though and have them go over any
contracts that you may be thinking of
putting in your document bank to send to
clients and then you know once the
attorneys reviewed them you know you can
start sending them off and because it's
contracts are so important in your
business what we're going to do is at
the end of this section of our video
we're going to have a separate lecture
from an attorney named Kerry Lee Ross
Kerry is a business law attorney in the
Dayton Ohio area and she's been kind
enough to put together some information
on things to look out for and to make
sure of when you're putting together -
the contracts the next thing and last
thing on my list to sign up for in this
is item number seven is insurance for
your business specifically professional
liability insurance what this is some
what this does I should say is it allows
you to be protected from liability in
the event that one of your customers
ever sues you so let's say you know a
customer hires you to build a website
and they say hey you know you did
something wrong as a result they don't
appear in search engines or you know
they hire you to build an app and they
claim he did something wrong and they
lost business as a result of it and then
they want to sue you having insurance it
means that you could just turn the
lawsuit over to your insurance even if
you don't agree with the lawsuit again
your insurance will cover it and your
insurance would pay all your legal bills
I mean we've never been sued in our
business but given a really small cost
of carrying insurance it just lets me
sleep better at night so I think right
now our premiums just went up so right
now we're paying call it a hundred
dollars a year it's really not very much
at all in the grand scheme of things
sign up for professional liability
insurance for your business
just call Geico or you know any similar
company and they can get you pointed in
the right direction as to who you want
to sign up for with that so your
administrative tasks again to get out of
the way before you even start taking
customers are get your company formed
and know your legal requirements get a
business address get a business bank
account get your required or needed
software and services signed up get your
contracts that you're gonna be sending a
clients ironed out preferably reviewed
by an attorney and also get an insurance
policy signed up and as I mentioned a
moment ago let's get to attorney Carrie
Ross for her lecture on contracts and
your business
you
hi my name is Kerri Ross I'm a business
attorney and an estate planning attorney
with Ross legal services in Dayton Ohio
I've been asked to speak with you today
about the importance of written
contracts in your software development
business we're going to talk about a few
key points in this segment first the
importance generally of well written
contracts throughout all aspects of your
business and then specifically in
connection with your software
development services second we'll talk
about typical formats for development
service contracts and some key
provisions that you may want to include
in your form to use with your clients
last we'll talk about some resources
available to you for purposes of
preparing your contract to use with your
clients the first thing I'll say is
having a well-written contract is very
important for all aspects of your
business you might be entering into a
lease for office space employment
agreements hiring your own independent
contractors or simply purchasing goods
in each case review the contract
negotiate it make sure that the final
product matches what your intentions are
so that the contract cannot be
questioned the purpose of a contract is
to memorialize your business transaction
it's your reference guide throughout an
ongoing transaction if there's a
question about who's obligated to do
what and when it's also your first line
of defense in the event of a dispute
your contract may even have provisions
that say what to do in the event of a
dispute do you have to go to arbitration
for example or are there notice
requirements before you can take any
kind of legal action when not reduced to
writing a handshake deal or something
you've agreed to via email or if it's
just poorly written in a written
contract you're open to disputes he-said
she-said problems coming up down the
road including maybe
getting paid maybe having to sue someone
or being sued for breach of contract or
maybe additional damages and sometimes
it's all of the above a real-world
example in the software development
field would be if you agreed to develop
an app for a customer and it has certain
functionality delivery dates you comply
with all of that at the end of the
agreement once you've delivered your app
and been paid you're asked to provide
ongoing maintenance and rather than
memorializing the terms of that
specifically in a contract you think
that everything's gone well with this
customer you agree to provide
maintenance two or three years go by and
all of a sudden the technology on which
your app was based is being phased out
and no longer functions and your client
is looking to you to say gee as part of
your maintenance maybe you need to
rebuild the entire app and you may say
well that wasn't in the scope of the
maintenance agreement so where do you
look you look at your written contract
and if you haven't memorialized the
terms of that clearly you could be left
in a lurch so at this point let's turn
our attention to the typical format for
software development contracts and some
key provisions you may want to include
so as we discussed in the last section
your written contract with your customer
is going to be the place where you
protect your business's interest and in
the context of app development or
software development you're protecting
you your talent is what's delivering the
project in the product at the end of the
day so that's really what your contract
is geared to protect clients will ask
you to provide a contract nine times out
of ten unless you're working with the
Microsoft's or Amazon's or large
development houses of the world your
clients will not normally have their own
development contract form so you want to
be prepared when you make that sales
pitch in advance so that you're not
holding up your sales process or closing
your deal because you need to go back to
the drawing board and come up with your
own contract if a client does present
you with their own form it's really
important to read this closely
understand what you're agreeing to
before you finalize it you may not feel
like you have that much leverage and you
may not but as long as you know what
you're signing ahead of time and make
sure that it's not going to impact your
activities going forward then that's
important things to watch out for would
be restrictive covenants that prevent
you from creating the same or similar
software or applications for people in
competing industries so non-competes non
solicitations those types of things
should really be watch outs the common
format that I typically see for services
agreements is an independent contractor
agreement plus a statement of work that
is attached to the back of it you can
call it an independent contractor
agreement in call it a services
agreement software development agreement
that really doesn't matter as
as the fact that you're going to have
your general basic terms that stay for
the most part the same from customer to
customer in your independent contract
agreement and this attachment on the
back where you can customize the
transaction to match what you're
actually being asked to perform common
provisions that you would see within the
independent contractor section clearly
you're going to identify the parties the
date you're signing the agreement in
each of these right off the bat but in
the contractor agreement section you'll
cover things like termination rights who
has the right to end the contract for
what reasons and what procedures in
place when that happens do you get paid
for partially completed work or how does
that work things like insurance
indemnification obligations where you're
risk sharing with the other side in case
something goes wrong those would be
negotiated in your independent
contractor agreement if you're granting
any warranties for your work or
specifically saying you're not granting
warranties for your work that's
typically handled in this section as
well a word of caution there depending
on where you are most state statutes
have specific requirements that implies
certain warranties unless you disclaim
them specifically and if you are going
to disclaim them you may have to write
that in a certain way in your agreement
to make it enforceable so please check
in with local counsel or really do some
statutory research if you have that
available to you to make sure you're
complying with the restrictions you may
also handle things such as the venue for
any lawsuits that potentially come up
governing law that would apply to your
contract particularly if you're located
in different states than your customer
for alternative dispute resolution
provisions that may require arbitration
or mediation prior to starting a lawsuit
now the statement of work is the juicy
part this is where you get to customize
the work or customize the
language to match the work you're
performing so you really want to get
into the deliverables here in specific
detail what are your deliverables and
when are you expected to deliver them is
this a pretty specific project that's
due all at one time is it phased
timeline for delivery what is due when
and what are your obligations related to
that payment terms you want to make sure
that you're specifically saying when you
want to get paid and for what if you're
delivering parts of the project along a
timeline will you get paid as those
things get delivered do you get paid on
an hourly rate a flat fee rate what are
the terms of your payment and when are
they due and keep in mind if this is
your form start where you want the
payment terms to start and let your
customer negotiate a change from there
if needed you may want to deal with
specifically customer responsibilities
depending on what you're doing you may
need the customer or a customer
representative assigned to you to
provide you with information or access
to systems to make sure their app works
what happens if they don't do that and
that delay is your timeline are you
responsible or are they responsible
here's also the place where you deal
with ongoing obligations
after the ultimate project is delivered
will you be maintaining the project are
you responsible for updates for the
project do you have any kind of other
ongoing application or I'm sorry ongoing
obligation after the delivery is done so
these are the kinds of things that
you're going to want to really nail down
inside of your independent contractor
agreement and the attached scope of work
so now we've gone over the need for
written contracts throughout your
business and we've specifically talked
about the format you may want to use and
some provisions that you might include
in your software development agreement
to be used with your own clients this
may seem pretty overwhelming at this
point a lot to think about the good news
is there are some resources available to
help you as you start to develop your
own form the first and most obvious
choice is to contact an attorney to help
prepare the contract on your behalf you
can explain your needs what the contract
will be used for and have the attorney
prepare that with those views in mind
this may not be in your budget I
understand that it is possible to
negotiate a flat fee with a lot of
attorneys which may save you some money
over an hourly rate arrangement it may
also be possible to negotiate a reduced
rate for a start up business if this is
still not within your budget I would
encourage you to contact your local
Chamber of Commerce or if you have like
we do in Dayton a small business startup
incubator firm you might be able to
contact them and receive some free or
reduced cost professional services
including legal services and others such
as accounting banking etc through their
programming if that's not available in
your area
there are numerous internet resources
that you can use to start a form such as
nola.com might be a good starting point
you can find these forms and I keep
stressing starting point because as I
mentioned in the previous segment there
are specific statutory requirements
depending on what kind of services
you'll be offering and what you want
your contract to cover I would encourage
all of you to at least have an attorney
read your form remembering that this is
an investment in your business that
you'll be using
hopefully over and over again with your
clients if you have any questions about
anything we've covered here please feel
free to contact me directly good luck
okay a big thanks to Carrie for talking
about the importance of contracts and
what to look for in a written contract
now let's talk about what you need to be
doing the market you're in a new
business
okay now that you're ready to start up
as a freelance developer let's talk
about some things you need to get out of
the way immediately so that you'll be
able to market your business properly
and there are other items other than
ones I'm going to talk about which
you'll need however these are just the
ones I'm stressing in this video some of
them may seem obvious but you would be
surprised at how many people decide to
open up their doors without having all
these items for lack of a better word
ready to go so let's go over a few
things to make sure you have you know
before you start trying to market
yourself to customers
number one is you need a website for
your new business number two is you need
a branded email you need a phone number
you need to have business cards you need
to sign up your various review profiles
on websites such as Google my business
and Yelp and things of that nature you
need to flush out your LinkedIn profile
and again these are just some of the
must-haves I mean obviously there are
other ones so let's go through each of
these in turn number one start a start a
website for your new development
business you would be surprised I have
actually seen people who go out and hold
themselves out as freelance software
developers freelance web developers and
they have an that they have not actually
put up a website for themselves or if
they have just to be frank it looks like
garbage so put up something nice your
website is important for multiple
reasons number one it's essentially your
storefront right think of it like this
if you were gonna hire somebody to build
you a website would you be a little
concerned if they didn't have a nice
website for themselves of course you
would so have a website up for yourself
before you start trying to hustle up
business and make it nice make it look
like you actually know what you're doing
make it look like it's something you
actually care about if you're looking
for inspiration or patterns or even some
good foundational templates to use for a
website for yourself I would suggest
going to the website html5 up these are
free html5 templates that again are
pretty good to use you know if you want
to just get something up quicker and
sooner rather than
later again that website is html5 up or
at a minimum you know if that's at a
minimum I should say or build yourself
something really nice from the ground up
again this is you showing off yourself
as a developer so have a website and
make sure it looks nice
number two is a branded email for your
business you got to realize as a
freelance developer you're gonna be
dealing with a lot of people who can
barely use a computer or barely use
their newfangled smartphone so you know
having a branded email goes a long way
towards validating you with people if
you email somebody from you know your
name at gmail.com you might as well be
emailing them from brand new developer
at gmail.com it goes a long way towards
legitimizing you having a branded email
we talked a little bit in the last
section about signing up a business
suite such as G suite or office 365
you'll get a branded email as part of
that but don't start emailing potential
clients and interacting with potential
clients from you know a free email
account list such as Gmail Yahoo you
know outlook calm or anything like that
the third thing to get is a phone number
dedicated to your business there are a
lot of reasons to keep your cell phone
and your business line separate do you
want your personal number on your
website probably not there do you want
to be able to go out at night and have
your phone ring and not be sure if it's
a customer or if it's just a friend of
yours or a family member calling I'm
sure you would like to be able to
separate your work in your business
lines fortunately having a separate
business phone number doesn't require
you to go out and pay for a second cell
phone you certainly can if you want that
you don't have to you can use a free
service from Google called Google Voice
and that will allow you to essentially
have a free voice over internet line
that will go to your cell phone so
you'll basically have two numbers on
your cell phone
Google Voice again it's free you know
you can talk and
talk text make calls from at receive
calls you know my wife has a Google
Voice line for her business on her phone
and it's free it's easy to use I mean I
would suggest for your business phone
number using Google Voice the next thing
you're going to want to get is their
business cards you're gonna be dealing
especially as a freelance developer
you're gonna be dealing with or are
likely I should say to be dealing with a
good number of local businesses and it
it is important to be able to hand them
a business card with that being said I
personally don't think it's worth it to
spend a lot of money on your business
cards you can get something that's
adequate from vistaprint you know
usually fifty bucks for a few hundred
cards but having a business card that
you can hand out is definitely important
you will be surprised at how many people
say to you okay do you have a card and
you look kind of silly if you don't have
a business card to hand them so have
your business cards with you and you
know like ready to roll before you even
start trying to hustle up business the
next thing you're gonna want to do is
get your various review profiles lined
up these are your profiles on websites
such as Yelp the review section of the
Facebook page for your new business the
review section on Google my business and
things like that these are places where
your customers will leave you good
reviews you're gonna want to ask them
for reviews we'll talk about that a
little later
but as I said these are places for your
customers to leave you good reviews
after you've completed work for them
it's important that you get these review
profiles signed up and maybe proactive
about getting reviews from customers
because there are there are meaningful
number of people who will not want to
hire you unless they can find good
reviews about your services and the
reason I say to get your review profiles
signed up before you even get your first
customer is because then you are ready
to ask that customer for a review you
don't want to you know finish your first
customers project and then you know and
then not being a position to ask them
for reviews because you haven't even
signed up the profiles yet so before you
even start going out and trying to
hustle up business
get your review profiles signed up the
primary ones I would focus on are again
Google my business Yelp the review
section of your Facebook page
you know those would probably be the big
ones the next thing is to completely
flush out and come and kind of make your
LinkedIn profile look really nice and
complete make it really clear what
skills you have you know hey you know if
you hey I know CSS I know JavaScript I
know HTML you know I'm fluent in other
languages make sure those are all listed
on your LinkedIn profile make sure your
LinkedIn profile says that you are
available for freelance work any
certifications you've gotten from free
code camp make sure your list those are
listed on your LinkedIn profile
there are also quick certification tests
you can take from LinkedIn for example
they have one for CSS only takes a few
minutes to do maybe a half hour to do
the test and you'll have a note citation
on your LinkedIn page saying that your
yeah you're considered certified in the
CSS and if as I said have your profile
say that you're available for freelance
work and you'll be surprised at how many
people just start randomly reaching out
to you through LinkedIn you know for
potential freelance work and also link
even if someone's not reaching out to
you LinkedIn is a place where people are
going to look to validate you in
addition to looking at the review
profiles I mentioned a minute ago so
those are the initial must-haves in
terms of being ready to market your new
business again just going through them
real fast in order get a website up go
to a website such as html5 up if you're
looking for inspiration or for a quick
template you can grab get a branded
email again G suite office 365 so those
kinds of services are gonna give you
that anyway get a phone number for your
business dedicated to your business I
would suggest using Google Voice that's
what my wife uses in her business I've
used it in the past it's free so
I don't really see any reason starting
out to pay for something get business
cards again something from Vistaprint is
typically find get your review profiles
signed up you know we're talking about
Yelp the face book reviews section
Google my business and get your LinkedIn
profile completely flushed out nicely
filled out and you do those things and
you're in a good spot to start marketing
start
I got a stress marketing your business
so with all that said let's talk about
why the last stage of getting your
business officially started is to begin
a process of lifelong learning and then
we'll be done with this module ok so the
last part of getting your business
started is recognizing that you are now
going to have to be a lifelong learner
if you want to be a successful
freelancer and what do I mean by this I
mean the fact that successful business
people are always trying to learn about
new topics relevant in some way relate
to their business it is a mistake to
think that ok I'm you know finishing or
I have finished the coding education I'm
going to do it free code camp and I'm
now done and I'm ready to strike out
into the world
completing free code camp is not the end
of learning how to code it is the
beginning of starting a career as a
coder in other words it is just the
first step and now you've got to start
learning about a whole lot of other
topics if you want to be successful as a
freelancer because what you will quickly
find out and when I say quickly I mean
almost immediately find out once you go
out on your own is that there is a whole
lot of things that go into B go into
being a business person besides learning
how to code so one thing I cannot stress
to you enough is in your spare time just
be reading on a regular basis you know
try to read 30 to 45 minutes a day at a
minimum and I got a stress
the at a minimum and when I say read I
don't mean you know just random articles
in magazines or fiction books or
whatever I would really suggest trying
to learn as much as you can about people
who have been very successful in their
fields look at what traits made them
successful and then try to emulate those
traits in your own business and there's
also just a lot of other books you can
read that help you figure out what it is
that successful people do in terms of
the habits they keep the thing I can't
stress enough is that you when you read
about successful people and people who
have achieved a lot what you will see is
common patterns common behaviors and
common habits between all of them and it
is important to remember that those
people don't have those habits because
they're successful they're successful
because they have those habits so if you
choose to have those habits in your own
business and in your own life you can be
successful as well so my my advice is
just read early read often about people
who have been successful in their field
and it doesn't even have to be a
successful software developer like Bill
Gates I mean just people who have been
successful in any kind of business a few
books I would suggest to get started
with if you haven't read these already
number one is profit first what this is
is a book that talks about essentially
accounting in your business but also how
to set up a financial budget for your
business a lot of businesses go out of
go out of business
due to poor financial management and now
that you're a freelancer you are a
business person like it or not and you
don't want your business to fail due to
poor financial management profit first
does a pretty good job of putting
together a system that is easy for
people to follow so if you're somebody
who already has a lot of discipline and
is already really good with managing
finances and you're good at keeping
personal and business finances separate
on top of that this may not be the book
for you but that being said I am willing
to bet a large number of people
watching this video would be open to
admitting that they've struggled with
personal financial management at some
point so reading profit first is good in
a sense that it will give you an
easy-to-follow system and just follow
the system and your business's finances
will take care of themselves so profit
first is book number one book number two
is how to win friends and influence
people this is a good one to read
because it really goes a long way in
terms of giving some tips that can be
useful in dealing with potential
customers dealing with people after
they've become your customers dealing
with other vendors and just individuals
you're gonna have to deal with in the
business world on you know just on a
daily basis well the book isn't
specifically about dealing with people
in a business setting it really gives a
lot of great information on how to deal
with individuals in different situations
and in proper context and if you're
somebody that feels like how do I dare
myself to people how do I sell how do I
make people want to hire me this is
probably a good book to read so number
two is how to win friends and influence
people by Dale Carnegie number three is
the millionaire next door this is a book
in which many millionaires were studied
over a long period of time and it'll
really dispel a lot of common
misperceptions about individuals who are
millionaires how they became
millionaires to habits of millionaires
and things of that nature it'll also go
a long way in showing how millionaires
stay millionaires through certain
financial habits I personally think this
book should be required reading before
anyone graduates from high school in the
United States so it's one I certainly
cannot suggest enough that people should
be read reading number four is a
small-time operator this is a book that
deals with small business in general
everything from habits you should be
keeping in terms of financial management
to day-to-day operations to getting your
taxes paid on time to you name it for
anyone who has never worked for
themselves and is now going out as a
freelance developer small-time operator
is a must read
number four is the I'm sorry number five
is the innovators by Walter Isaacson
this is essentially a history of
computing and computer science and it
goes all the way from the creation of
the first computer and the concepts of
the first computer if Ada Lovelace all
the way up through essentially where we
are today and it'll really give you an
appreciation of how no one person not
even Steve Jobs not even Bill Gates not
even name an individual no one person
had an outsized impact on computing and
has really just been kind of a brick by
brick building of you know of computer
science from the from its founding and
through now and it really just gives you
an appreciation of what different
individuals has done it's an inspiring
book to read and I just think it's a
must learn must read for anyone who's
just learned to code and is striking out
on their own and the final book I would
suggest reading is the everything store
which is a story about Amazon and the
founding of Amazon by Jeff Bezos and how
the company grew to where it is today
the thing you will really take away from
this book when you read it is that
Amazon got where it is today in large
part by a never ending focus on customer
service I mean whether it's just you as
a freelance developer know it's in your
basement writing code or whether you're
Jeff Bezos writing Amazon running Amazon
and everything in between customer
service has to be your pet number one
priority there's can be no other
priority that comes before customer
service and reading the everything store
will really help you understand this so
like I said these are just a few
suggestions to get started and I would
really suggest reading 30 to 45 minutes
a day for those of you watching this
video you know if we could line
everybody up a year from now for people
who have succeeded as a freelancer and
people who haven't I guarantee you the
people who have succeeded have probably
read more consistently than the people
who haven't so you know if all of that
said let's move on
next part of our lesson
okay we're to the
lessons where we're going to talk about
how to get clients for your new business
after all as a freelance web developer
freelance software developer you're not
going to be in business very long if you
don't have customers right so really
we're gonna look at a few things number
one we're gonna look at how to get
customers in the short term because you
need revenue today and number two we're
gonna look at how to build your business
over the long term
how you get customers over the long term
is going to be very different than how
you immediately get customers today for
your short term start up business all
right so before we dive into those let's
look at number one why is it important
to understand the difference between the
long term and the short term and then
let's quickly talk about how to sell
your services to people once you
understand the need to focus on the long
term you'll see the difference between
that and short term business building
and then you'll also see that once you
know how to sell yourself to people you
can just be far more effective in terms
of growing your business
so first the need to focus on both the
short term and the long term in your
business the need to focus on the short
term is obvious right because as I said
a moment ago if you don't have customers
today you're going to be in business for
about 30 seconds so you need to get
customers today no one disputes that you
may not be taking your dream jobs you
name may not be getting the work that is
your first choice but you need work so
again you're gonna go about doing things
to get work today that are getting you
work through not necessarily the most
how shall we say sustainable ways okay
but again you need work today so that's
what you're gonna do over the long term
however you're going to build a brand
meaning that you're going to build a
business where instead of you going out
and getting work through non sustainable
means people are just coming to you and
you're getting the work without having
to put much effort into getting it this
is work that will be higher paying this
is work more along the lines of what you
want to be doing long term and more
importantly if you're not putting time
and resources into getting that work it
becomes much more profitable for you so
if you only focus on the short term
you can get some business and that's
what you're going to have to do in the
beginning but if that is your sole focus
and your constant your just constantly
and I do mean constantly in that state
of trying to hustle up new work looking
for the next job things of that nature
and you just never really get your
business out of second gear if however
you keep your focus on building a
long-term brand you grow your profits in
your business really fast so that's why
it's important to in the short term go
out and get some clients do what you
have to do to hustle up work but also be
building a long-term brand so I cannot
stress that enough number two is how to
actually sell yourself to customers and
eat whether you're trying to sell the
people in the short-term or whether
you're trying to sell the people in the
long-term I cannot stress enough that
you need to view yourself as a problem
solver we talked about this in an
earlier section of the video when we
were talking about the need to provide
value to your clients when you are
selling yourself to your clients and
trying to sell your services to a client
what you need to do is come to learn
about the clients business and identify
the client's problems and explain how
your software is or your website or
whatever you're building explain how
your product is going to solve those
problems okay don't come to them and say
here's my experience here's what I've
done la-de-da-de-da say you have this
problem here's how I'm going to solve it
people are going to be much much much
and I mean much more receptive to that
kind of an approach and you'll wind up
doing a lot more in sales this is
something I talked about at length in a
previous video for free code camp and
we're going to link to that video in the
description below so we don't rehash too
much of it here but when selling
yourself to customers I cannot stress
enough present yourself as a problem
solver so in short you need customers in
the short term we're going to talk in a
moment about how to get those it's
important that you keep a focus on
building your brand long term and when
selling yourself to customers it's
really important that you present
yourself as a solver of their problems
all right so with all that said let's
get on to how to build your business
over the short term
you
okay let's take a few minutes
some things you're going to do to get
clients in the short-term as we just
said in our intro that need to get
clients in the short-term for your
freelance business is obvious right
because after all if you don't get
clients immediately you're not going to
be working for yourself for it very long
so in just a moment I'm going to get
into five different ways that you can go
about getting clients immediately
getting customers today and generating
some revenue before I get into that
though the one thing I want to stress is
that the things you're going to do in a
short-term to get clients they're gonna
be a little more labor intensive and a
little more costly than the things
you're going to do over the long term to
get your business and that's alright
again these things like I said while
they in the short-term while they may be
costly while they may be time intensive
the bottom line is they're necessary
because if you don't have clients today
you are not going to do very well and
you're not going to be around for very
long so let's look at five things you
can do in the short term to get clients
for your startup business number one is
simply gonna be people you know and I'll
talk about this in a minute you're just
gonna put put out there to people you
know that you're now engaging in this
kind of work
number two is gonna be lead websites
such as upwork and fiber we'll talk
about those in a minute number three is
going to be leveraging your LinkedIn
profile number four and people are
surprised when I say this is gonna be
leveraging websites such as Craigslist
and number five is gonna be good
old-fashioned networking so let's go
through each of these in turn number one
is as I said just putting your name out
there to people you know you would be
surprised at how much work you can get
by simply making everyone you know aware
of the fact that you are now engaging in
this type of work I'm not suggesting
that you go around the friends and
family members and continuously harass
them into letting you do build them a
website or letting you do something for
them what I'm saying though is that you
need to simply put out there hey just so
you know I'm available to do this type
of work let me give you a few examples
of what I mean by that in one of our
businesses our main service is building
websites for very small to medium sized
companies and usually
you know kind of like the small
mom-and-pop shops type companies so just
as an example when we started that
business I made I just kind of casually
mentioned to one friend of mine hey just
so you know we're gonna be doing this
type of work you know like etc etc if
you know anybody that needs that kind of
work just let me know and very quickly
that friend said to me that her mother
had actually recently started a church
and then we wound up building a website
for the church I also mentioned to a
neighbor that I was doing this type of
work and very quickly that led to
another referral the same thing and I
had similar situations with other people
that we knew so when I told people hey
we do this kind of work that was gonna
be the only time I tell them I'm not
gonna like sit there and tell them over
and over I'm not gonna like harass them
I'm not gonna sit there and say just a
reminder I do this kind of work just
casually make people aware that you're
doing this type of work and do it in a
way where you don't sound like you're
trying to sell them something again hey
just letting you know and you will be
surprised how quickly referrals can come
in that way as I said we started that
little side project business I just
talked about and very quickly we started
getting referrals simply by letting
people I know know that we were doing
this kind of work so just putting
yourself out there like that can go a
long way and I can't stress that enough
as a place to start
the second place to look for getting
clients for your business is lead
service websites such as upwork and
fiber what upwork is it's a website
where essentially people looking for
services such as web development or
software development will go on up work
state what it is they want and what
they're willing to pay and then you can
go online and bid on the job a lot of
times you'll be bidding on work at a
dollar amount what for which is way less
than what you would normally charge for
this kind of work but again in the
beginning it's work so you know it can
generate some revenue for you while
you're getting started the thing that I
would say is important to do when you're
using websites such as upwork thumbtack
things of that nature is to make sure
that your
profile on the site is fully completed
make sure you list all your experience
include examples of your work and things
of that nature make sure make sure
people review you on those sites after
they're happy with your services all
those kinds of things will make your
bidding process more effective so the
upside of these kinds of services is the
fact that people go on there looking for
the services you're providing so it
makes finding a customer a lot easier
the downside is again you're working for
a reduced rate a lot of the time and
you're also paying for the lead so it's
not gonna be the most profitable thing
in the world but in the short term it is
work to do and it is money to be made
another option as I mentioned a second
ago is fiber fiber works a little
different than a website such as up work
what fiber is is you essentially go
online create a profile people can come
to your profile and say what they're
willing to pay and then fiber will take
a cut of that so again you're usually
gonna wind up working for reduced rates
on a website such as fiber and and top
of that you're paying a percentage to
fiber so when you're looking at those
kinds of things that's important to
consider the reduced profitability
weight against the fact that the
customers are typically being or
essentially I should say being brought
to you so again pros and cons on those
third thing on our list is leveraging
LinkedIn it's really important to on
your LinkedIn profile make sure that you
are stating that you are a freelance
developer that you work for yourself put
the name of your business on there and
make sure you list in your bio and in
your by lines that you are available to
do this kind of work on a freelance
basis make sure you're including all
your qualifications include examples of
your work on your LinkedIn profile and
there are such a shortage right now of
software developers and web developers
that you will be surprised at how many
people will reach out to you and ask if
you are available to do work for them so
LinkedIn is a good way to get business
again just as I said make sure your
profile is filled out all the way on
there number four and this is one that
people kind of raise an eyebrow when I
say it is to
have a nice ad on your local Craigslist
section so for example if you live in
name of City go on the name of city page
for Craigslist and you know under
certain the services section you can put
in that you are available to do web
design or whatever kind of work it is
you're doing don't just put up a quick
craigslist post saying that hey i do
this work call me at this number
actually take the time write out a nice
ad put it on Craigslist include a
graphic the craigslist supports the
graphic and a width of 450 pixels at a
height of 600 pixels put the nice
graphic on there put as I said a nice ad
on there and you will be surprised at
the fact that you get some calls through
there to this day Craigslist remains a
highly valuable and highly underutilized
resource for getting work now the work
you're gonna get through Craigslist is
not going to be the most profitable type
of work there as these are typically
going to be low dollar websites you know
people want to spend a few bucks for
just some basic coding or something like
that again it's not you're certainly not
going to get rich off its I'm gonna be
all the money in the world but it only
cost you five dollars to run the ad and
you will get some work out of that the
important thing is to post consistently
and to stick with it the last thing on
our list is good old-fashioned
networking and by networking I mean
going out and meeting with other
business owners to drum up work for
yourself what I don't suggest for
networking is going door-to-door or
going around at different kinds of
businesses trying to introduce yourself
I also don't suggest going to functions
that are mostly attended by other
developers that is something I see in a
lot of different professions so for
example attorneys tend to network with
other attorneys you know accountants
tend to network with other accountants a
lot of software developers tend to
network with other software developers
and beyond says just not a very
effective way of leveraging networking
and getting customers instead what you
want to be doing is
meeting with people who in turn work
with your customers so for example if
you are let's say starting up a
freelance web design business and what
you might want to do is get hooked up
with a digital marketer who doesn't
actually do web design that maybe
manages pay-per-click or something for
somebody those type of people are almost
always looking for people to build
websites on behalf of their clients so
that would in turn be a good referral
source for you one of the best ways are
I should say best resources to find good
networking opportunities is a group
called BNI that's business networking
international they're throughout the
United States and with lots of local
chapters and pretty much everywhere so
go on BNI is website and find local
chapters in your area and join up there
is an annual fee for joining BNI it is
well worth it
the idea of BNI is has a few aspects to
it number one is they only allow one
person in a chapter per an area so for
example if you join BNI as a web
designer they're not going to allow
another web designer in that chapter so
which elect gives you some exclusivity
and for obvious reasons is good for you
and then you'll have a chapter with one
web designer one auto mechanic one
accountant one finance manager one local
doctor just name that one real-estate
agent just name the type of business and
you will have one of each in there and
then once you attend then you'll attend
weekly meetings and once you attend
these weekly meetings the goal of BNI is
for everybody in the group to
essentially open up their referral books
to one another so in other words you are
a web designer in the BNI group friend
of yours needs an auto mechanic you
refer them to the auto mechanic in the
BNI group the auto mechanic nobody knows
somebody who needs their house painted
so he refers them to the house painter
in the BNI group it turns out that
there's a doctor in our you know
physician in the BNI group and it turns
out he knows somebody that needs website
he just refers the site he refers them
to you so in other words it's not
something where person one person two
are directly referring things to each
other all the time it's just that
everybody in the group is referring
things to other people in the group and
a lot of that business will have a way
of coming back to you so attending a
networking group such as BNI is a really
good start for a way to get business in
the short term networking can be very
very time-consuming so that is why I've
got it on our list of things to do to
build business in the short term it is a
very time consuming so a lot of people
like to say well I go out and I network
because it's free well it's only free if
you value your time at zero okay and
your time is worth a whole lot more than
zero so in the short term networking
functions and networking events and
joining networking groups is an OK way
to get business but as you build a brand
long term those are things that you're
gonna want to get away from so to sum up
we're really talking about five ways to
build business and grow your company
over the short term number one is people
you know as I said just put it out there
that you're doing this kind of work you
know don't harass your friends it's a
good way to make sure they're not your
friends anymore
number two excuse me is using services
such as upwork thumbtack and fiber
number three is leveraging LinkedIn
number four is a website such as
Craigslist and number five is good
old-fashioned networking so now that
we've gone over all of those let's talk
about how it is where you're going to
build your brand over the long term
which will greatly increase your profits
okay let's talk about building your
business over the long term now and
having a long-term sustainable business
is going to look a lot different than
the things you're doing to get business
in the short term as we talked about in
the last section of our video your
short-term business activities are
really going to focus on using lead
websites going to networking events
things that are either very expensive
things that are very time-consuming
things that lead to you taking work at
reduced rates those are all good ways to
make a few bucks today to keep your new
business running and to help you make a
little extra money while you're focusing
on building a long-term brand the reason
why building a long-term brand is so
important is having an actual brand that
you have ownership and control of allows
you to number one charge more for your
services you'll actually be charging
more of what you deserve to be making
for the work you're doing number two it
also allows you to save time and
resources on getting work in other words
instead of you putting out money instead
of you putting out a lot of time to get
work people are going to be coming to
you so think of it like this people
coming to you and saying let me pay you
full price as opposed to you going to
people and saying here's a reduced work
I can do so for obvious reasons having a
brand is way way way and a whole bunch
of ways more profitable than the things
you're going to need to do in the short
term so while you're engaging in those
short-term activities that we talked
about in the our last section I cannot
stress enough that you need to be making
time for the long term activities that
were about to talk about and if you
don't make time for those long term
activities next thing you know you've
been freelancing and working for
yourself for five years and you are
still engaging in those short-term
activities and not making very much
money that can be a trap that is
actually very easy for people to fall
into so the best thing you can do is
just set aside the time every week to
say you know what I don't care how busy
I am I'm going to focus on these
long-term activities so what are the
long-term activity
you're going to engage in to make sure
you're building a brand and that you're
charging more for your services and your
not putting time and effort into getting
customers number one is simply building
a referral base and we'll talk about
that in a second number two is going to
be leveraging a blog for yourself and
number three is going to be leveraging
platforms such as YouTube if you focus
on these three things then next thing
you know like I said people are coming
to you and study you going to them and
people are paying you more instead of
less so let's look at each of these in
term again number one is simply getting
referrals from people and getting a
repeat business referrals and repeat
business I'm saying that's so saying
that so many times because it's so
important it's so important I'm going to
say it again referrals and repeat
business here's the important thing to
understand about getting referrals from
former customers and having other former
customers come back to you to do
additional work in the future when you
look at very successful businesses they
don't get a proportionately higher
number of phone calls and what I mean by
that is let's say you've got developer 1
and developer 2 here's developer one
here's developer - this developer does
five times the revenue every year of
this developer let's go 5x that does not
mean that this developer gets five times
as many brand new client calls every
month as this developer if you want to
get to where you are making the
substantially more than other people you
have to do it by getting referrals from
former customers and getting repeat
business from former customers it is
simply too expensive and too
time-consuming to constantly be getting
brand new business that's not stemming
from work you have already done it's
just not possible to succeed without
doing that think of it in these terms
customer comes to you once a website you
build it for $3,000 right you do a
really good job for that customer three
to six months later that customer refers
you somebody you didn't build that
person a website for $2,500
three to six months later that second
customer the referred one they refer you
somebody you build that one a website
for say three thousand dollars your
marketing or whatever you're doing to
get clients from the outside world only
yield at one phone call
yielded the phone call from the very
first customer however by doing good
work that one customer turned into three
new customers or rubs our two new
customers and that total of three
customers and as a result of that you
also have three potential or first
referral sources out there right now all
from one phone call right and some of
that can also happen with free P
business and so on and so forth
in other words if you get one phone call
you do a great job for the person and
over the course of three or four years
you know you do three or four different
projects for that person one phone call
yielded three or four different jobs
essentially so that kind of an approach
and focusing on referrals and repeat
business is the way to grow your
business exponentially so how do you
make sure you're getting referrals and
repeat business well it may sound simple
but you'd be surprised the first thing
is good old-fashioned customer service
call people back return respond to
people's emails be honest with them
about how long something is going to
take do what your say you're going to do
if you tell somebody you're going to
have something done by Thursday have it
done by Thursday if you're not going to
have it done by Thursday make sure you
call them Thursday and or email them
Thursday and explain to them that this
isn't done i'm sorry here's why it's not
done here's when it will be done don't
make them chase you around saying hey
that you said this was gonna be done on
Thursday where is it good old-fashioned
customer service and saying the that
what you're gonna do and doing it are
the most surefire ways to lead to that
repeat business and those referrals that
we just talked about I cannot stress
this enough you may think duh when I'm
saying provide good service to people
but you would be surprised at how few
people out there actually provide the
kind of service that you would probably
want to receive yourself so I'm going
that extra mile going above and beyond
can really go a long way and as simple
as that sounds it takes work - you gotta
remember it takes work to provide good
customer service right so do that work
and put in the time and you will be
shocked at how fast your business grows
and this is true whatever industry
you're in whether you're a freelance
developer of some sort whether you're a
real estate agent whether you are you
know an accountant or some other type of
professional I just cannot stress enough
good service leads to a whole lot more
business and that is how you grow your
business exponentially through referrals
and repeat business so that's number one
number two for building your freelance
business over the long term is
leveraging a blog and by this I mean you
need to be blogging regularly attach
your blog to your website and you need
to be blogging regularly on issues
important to your customer base one of
the big mistakes a lot of people make
with a blog is they start writing on
things that they think are interesting
the focus of your blog needs to be
providing useful information to your
customer base and this is something I
see all the time like for example I have
on our blog on our business for our
business which deals primarily with
software answers for law firms we have
provided a lot of information about how
law firms can be more efficient in their
day to day operations we've written a
lot of information about how they can
leverage different software applications
in a law firm and so on so forth
attorneys doing Google searches on
making their practices more efficient
then land on those articles and they
explore our blog further when they start
to look at some of the solutions we
provide they realize that they may need
our services and they pick up the phone
and call us so in other words by
providing useful information to our
customer base through a blog our
customer base lands on our website they
then turn and they in turn then call us
so leveraging a blog that provides
useful information to your customers is
one of the best ways to get business and
this winds up being incredibly time
effective there a blog posts that I
wrote three four or five even in some
instances even six years ago that are
still still yielding
phone calls to our business today so in
other words a couple hours to write a
blog post five years ago people are
still calling us because we own it no
one can take it away from us okay that
is incredibly time effective in terms of
going out and getting a business in
addition to a blog and other great
source to leverage is YouTube YouTube is
one of the most pop actually one of the
most popular search engines and the
world people go on YouTube all the time
looking for information if you're gonna
do a YouTube channel to drum up business
the thing I cannot stress enough is just
like with a blog provide information
that is useful to people so again
provide information that your potential
customers are looking for so for example
let's say you want to focus on websites
for small businesses which is something
we do in one of our businesses I'm just
using this as an example I want to build
websites for small businesses I start a
YouTube channel on it a lot of small
businesses might be trying to do their
own website say with Wix or like
WordPress or something like that and
then they'll get frustrated with it and
maybe decide to call it developer so
what we can do in our business is do a
YouTube channel on how to is like here's
how to do X in your Wix website here's
how to do Y in your WordPress website
and then those small businesses start to
use our YouTube channel as a resource to
meet their needs and over time when they
realize that Wix and WordPress actually
can't meet their meet their needs fully
or their needs go beyond what's our
WordPress they then turn around and call
us because we're the people they've been
getting information from this whole time
so again providing useful information to
people is the best way to leverage a
YouTube channel so doing these three
things I've just talked about
really again I kind of stressed enough
allows you to build a brand it results
in people coming to you instead of you
going out hustling up work and it allows
you to charge more for your work so
while you're growing your business in
the short term and while you're doing
the things you need to do to get clients
in the short term the things you need to
be focusing on is making sure you're
building a referral base and a reap
there's no space and you do that by
providing the absolute highest levels of
customer service meeting your deadlines
and doing the things you say you're
gonna do you want to leverage the blog
again while you're busy in your business
you need to make sure you're setting
aside time to blog and that you're
writing on issues that are answering
your clients questions addressing your
client's concerns and providing the kind
of information your potential clients
are looking for you want to apply that
same approach to the third thing which
is a YouTube channel and again providing
value and usefulness to people is the
best way to make sure that they are
excuse me that they are potentially
interested in calling you if you do
these three things you start to see
yourself as I said having a brand that
in turn leads to more leads to much more
money it also leads to you having much
more time because you're not doing
things like going to networking events
and the other things that you have to do
to get business in the short-term so
with all of that said let's move on to
the next part of our video which is how
to go about managing your business on a
day to day basis
a
our video where we're going to talk
about managing your business on a day to
day basis and we're gonna break that
down into two parts first we're going to
talk about managing your administrative
tasks on a day to day basis and by
administrative tasks I mean anything
that is not actually related to
development things such as filing your
business's taxes doing your bookkeeping
filing paperwork with your Secretary of
State so on and so forth
so managing those kinds of tasks and the
second thing we'll talk about will be
managing your substitutive work on a day
to day basis and your substantive work
is the actual development work and you
want to make sure you're doing that in a
way that yields as much profit as
possible so we'll talk about
administrative and substantive and how
to make sure you're managing yourself
now
before we get into those two things the
biggest point I want to stress is that's
time for you to start thinking of
yourself as a business person it's
really common for me to have
conversations with self-employed
individuals who will say something like
well I'm not a business person I'm a
software developer or I'm not a business
person I'm a real estate agent or I'm
not a business person I'm an attorney or
something like that once you start
working for yourself if you take the
attitude of you know I'm not a business
person I'm an X then you really don't
need to worry about being a business
person and I say that because you're
going to be out of business so fast that
the problem of being a business person
will take care of itself and when I say
that I don't mean it to sound to flip
but it really is true and the people who
succeed as freelance developers and
essentially and eventually I should say
grow their freelance business into a
real business are the ones who
understand that as soon as you strike
out on your own whether you have one
customer whether you're running
Microsoft you are now in business for
yourself okay so you need to understand
that things like working efficiently and
dealing with your administrative tasks
those aren't optional these are things
you're gonna have to do and you just
don't have a choice in the matter
anymore and that is a choice you made
once you decided to strike out on your
own so understand that you are a
businessperson do
so will one allow you to stay in
business and to allow you to make a lot
more money so with all that said let's
move on to how to manage your
administrative affairs on a day to day
basis
okay so we're going to talk about the
importance of dealing with your
business's administrative affairs on a
day to day basis and the reason I am
talking about this first before I get
into talking about how to manage your
substantive work is that the
administrative work is a crucial topic
to address lots and lots and lots and a
whole bunch of lots of businesses
especially freelance developers get
themselves in trouble not because
they're bad at development or they
service our customers poorly that's
because they do a really bad job at
their administrative work and then that
creates problems down the road for
example suppose that's just as a
hypothetical you need to file a document
with the Secretary of State and you fail
to do so and you're right in the middle
of a coding project for somebody and
because you didn't file that document to
secretary of state six months later
while you're in the middle of that
coding project a notice shows up from
the Secretary of State saying you've
lost your right to legally do business
so now you need to put that coding
project on hold and take a day or two to
deal with your administrative snafu as a
result of this you miss a deadline to
the customer the customer is unhappy you
know obviously the customer is never
going to refer you anybody the customer
is never going to you know come back to
you again for more work and that's just
a simple example of how not dealing with
administrative tasks can get in the way
of you doing your substantive work and I
totally understand that it's not fun to
do administrative tasks right it's not
fun to you know fill out stuff for the
Secretary of State it's not fun to do
your bookkeeping it's not fun to do
those kinds of things that's not why you
signed up for free code camp that's not
why you became a software developer in
the first place but unfortunately those
things are part of the job and if you
don't pay attention to them failing to
complete those administrative tasks
timely and handle them correctly will
lead to problems with your actual
substantive business okay so this is why
I'm talking about the administrative
tasks first
so the first administrator
issue I'm going to talk about in the
management of your business is the
biggest one and that's your day-to-day
financial management I could do easily a
very long video course on how to manage
your freelance business from a financial
standpoint and because it would be so
long I'm not going to dive into all of
it now what I'm gonna do is suggest a
you read a book which I suggested
earlier in this course and that book is
called profit first what profit first
does is it lays out a framework which
can manage your business's finances for
you so in other words it puts a
framework in place you follow the
framework and your business's finances
kind of manage themselves at that point
and financial management is one of the
biggest things where a lot of people get
themselves into trouble one of the
biggest things you want to avoid is
what's called bank balance accounting
and lots of small business owners are
guilty of this where they go online they
look at their bank account they see a
balance you know on the screen and they
just assume that's that's how much money
they have without any thought of you
know what they've got to be paying
what's coming out of it and so on so
forth following the methodology laid out
in profit first can I help you avoid
bank balance accounting but also just
help you make sure that your business is
staying on the sustainable path and in
addition to reading profit first just
remember that your business's bank
account is not your personal bank
account you just can't go rate it
whenever you want some money what you
want to do is set up a system where you
were only allowed to take a certain
amount of money out of the business at
any given time and a certain amount of
money has to stay in the business at a
given time and the profit first book
really does a good job of laying all
that out for you so if you can avoid
financial mismanagement you will avoid a
lot of the problems that or I should say
administrative problems they get
freelance developers in the trouble and
what I would suggest to you is a easy to
use method for making sure you are
following good financial management
habits for your business is to read
profit first and follow it again it's
not enough to
the book actually have to follow the
methodology it's laying out for you
the second big part in addition to
following a methodology like the one in
profit first to making sure that your
finances are managed properly is to do
your accounting regularly this is so
important I cannot stress it enough do
your accounting regularly you should be
using bookkeeping software like WAV or
QuickBooks or something of the sort in
our business we use wave and I see way
way way way way too many small
businesses that don't do their books
until the end of the year or even worse
at the end of the year they essentially
just print off all their bank statements
and dump it on an accountant and say ok
here figure out how much money I made
last year
well not doing the books in your
business on a regular basis means you
never actually know if you're making
money or not and if you are making money
how much you're making and if you're
losing money how much you're losing and
then it becomes easy for you to think
well it seems like I'm doing good well
seem can be a very tricky thing you can
get yourself in a lot of trouble by
going off of how things seem what you
need is objective data in front of you
in other words you need a monthly
statement showing here's how much money
my business took in here's how much went
out here's how much I've made here's how
much I lost you've got to do your books
on a regular basis if you get up and the
first thing every day
before you start work just do your
bookkeeping for the day before in other
words download the prior day's
transactions and reconcile them and your
accounting software then you get in the
habit of doing that and your books are
just done all the time and it doesn't
take more than a few minutes a day when
you're just starting out if you have
very few transactions at a minimum do
your books once a week or at worst once
a month but do your books on a regular
basis I cannot stress this enough that
is the only way you're actually going to
know how much money you're making or how
much money you're losing and what you
need to adjust another benefit of doing
your books on a regular basis is it also
helps you catch expenses you might not
realize you've signed up for that you're
still paying so do your books regularly
so in terms of managing your finances
read profit first
follow the methods laid out in profit
first avoid using your personal bank
account or I'm sorry your business's
bank account as a piggy bank you can't
just raid it whenever you want and the
fourth part of managing your finances is
doing your books daily so that's keeping
your finances in order which again is
one of the biggest administrative
problems that a lot of freelancers run
into and in terms of the second aspect
of your administrative problems or
administrative tasks I should say that
you've got to manage on a day to day
basis that is just really all the
different things that come of being a
small business person to having to file
your business license every year if
you're in a state that requires that to
having to file any documentation you
need to file with County sales tax
boards let's say you'll find that as an
entrepreneur there is an endless flow of
paperwork that you need to fill out and
you need to stay on top of it so the
best thing to do is don't take the
approach of I'll do this later when a
piece of paper comes across your desk
and you look at it and you say oh okay I
have to file something with the
Secretary of State just deal with it on
the spot
don't let these things pile up okay
letting these kinds of tasks pile up is
another of the big mistakes I see from
entrepreneurs and again they might find
out they've lost the ability to do
business legally because they've let
these things pile up if you just deal
with them as soon as they come up then
they're done there you don't have to
worry about them they're just taken care
of and they probably don't even take
that long
what takes a long time is when you let
these things to grow into a stack this
high and then you have to stop
everything you're doing and spend days
if not weeks dealing with all that stuff
so deal with your administrative tasks
as they come up just treat them as a
priority that has to be dealt with
because by getting them out of the way
you can focus on the substantive work
more okay so deal with those things
immediately after they arise that is
just something it is so important and if
you do that you will have an advantage
over other freelancers so in short if
you want to
a leg up in your new business you guys
you have to take your administrative
tasks seriously you have to manage your
finances appropriately which cut which
entails everything we just talked about
reading profit first following the
methods in it not rating your bank
account doing your books on a regular
basis and you have to deal with your
administrative tasks as soon as they
come up and if you need help with them
retain a business lawyer to help you
okay but if you do those things you
prevent your administrative tasks from
getting in the way of your actual
business and then you make more money so
with all that said let's get on to our
accounting and financial management
course from Aaron Lehrer of kpi
bookkeeping hey code campers my name is
Aaron lair I'm the owner of KPI
bookkeeping and consulting and I'm
excited to go over with you today how to
manage your finances as a freelancer and
now this isn't everyone's most exciting
or favorite topic but it is so important
if you can get off on the right step and
create good habits you will be so much
more ahead of other freelancers as well
as business owners because you will know
your income your expenses you'll know
how to manage them and you'll know what
decisions to make and what changes to
make within your freelancing business so
I'm going to dive at divide this up into
three topics this first one is just
going to be the real basics 101 second
topic we're gonna do a brief overview of
your chart of accounts or your income
and expense buckets once you get inside
your accounting software and then the
third topic we're gonna cover a profit
and loss statement just kind of how to
read it and what it looks like alright I
hope you find this helpful and best of
luck thanks okay so if there are just
three things to do if you don't want to
watch anything else passes just three
things is number one keep your business
and personal finances separate number
two save at least 25-30 percent of your
gross income and number three have an
accounting software and actually use it
so let's get back to number one keeping
your business finances separate from
your personal so this one is just
if there's one thing you need to just at
least do this one this is huge it'll
save you so much time so much have a
headache and money when it comes to
getting your taxes done and it's as
simple as when you're ready to start
freelancing go open your own business
bank account checking business checking
account and savings account and any
business transactions you occur those
all need to come out of that business
account as well as if you had need to
get a credit card open a credit card
just for your business expenses and then
keep all of your personal expenses
separate just like the way you've had
them running through your own personal
accounts this will be huge when it comes
to tax time and you'll be able to
separate the differences between your
freelancing and business activities
versus your personal activities number 2
save 25 to 30 percent of your gross
income for taxes I know that sounds like
a lot I know it sounds crazy but it's
definitely something you need to do and
I also think you really need to factor
this in when you start to give quotes
and create your pricing structures the
government wants right off the bat 15.3%
for self-employment tax now that other
10 to 15% is just on the other income
you receive so this is why you want to
set that savings account so as you get
your business income coming into your
business checking account I would say
immediately or at least once a week
take that income take that percentage of
25 to 30 percent and then dump that
right into your savings account so
you're into your business savings
account so that is stored away tucked
away for taxes and then when tax time
comes there's no big surprises you've
got the money you're good to go
so that is huge I think this one
surprises a lot of people a lot of
freelancers they don't realize how high
self-employment taxes and how much taxes
will be taken out so do keep that in
mind when you go to price when you
create pricing structures and then
number three have a accounting software
and actually use it so I get a lot of
clients that
have accounting software's they have
things maybe synced up but they're not
necessarily using it and I understand
you get busy and if you can't use it or
you don't know how they then reach out
and get some help with it but when you
go to select an accounting software I
would get three major things one it can
connect to your bank accounts and credit
cards so these are typically gonna all
be your cloud-based accounting
accounting software programs number two
you can send your invoices from that
platform or software whichever you
choose and it has a Pay Now feature this
will save you so much time and hassle as
far as tracking your your invoices and
then number two is you can pull a profit
and loss report at minimum and profit
loss support ideally you'd like to be
able to pull a balance sheet and a cash
flow statement but you at least want to
be able to pull a profit and loss report
okay so let's move on to some accounting
software's these are just a list of
probably my top four the first to waive
and fresh books these are great for if
you're just starting out they're very
user friendly they've got a great
interface on them they're for the most
part pretty intuitive
I'm gonna go over a little bit of things
you need to keep your eye on on the next
video but these are great to just get
started that you can invoice from them
you can receive payments it'll track you
can connect all your bank accounts and
credit cards so these are great starters
now if you you know let's say you want
something you just want to stick with
one and you want something that can grow
with you those next two would be
QuickBooks Online in Xero these are
great for more full-on businesses I mean
you can still use them as a freelancer
these are more robust there's a lot more
kind of going behind the scenes and I
would say if you're just starting out
they might have a little more - many
more bells and whistles than you might
need but that doesn't mean you can't use
them you can still certainly use them
you might want to get some training on
those and even if you feel like you need
to get training on the other two waving
fresh books I would definitely reach out
and look for those but going back to
QuickBooks and 0 these are great but
again these will grow with you so
you might not need these starting out
you can certainly start in them but
there they will grow when she start
having employees you've got a lot more
going on within your finances so this is
just a brief overview the next step or
the next video we're gonna get into is
I'm gonna kind of get into once you're
in your accounting software what you
really need to do and what you need to
watch out for all right thanks let's
move into your accounting software so
you know how to get paid faster you know
how to manage your receipts let's move
into that accounting software and kind
of get an idea of what we're looking at
and what we're dealing with so just a
warning this is a brief overview this is
not going I'm not getting into any
particular software so I do want to
advise you that if you have questions
reach out get help or get training from
someone or take a course if you feel
like you need to kind of get a better
grip on this because if you start this
out right it'll be much easier for you
in the long run okay let's get started
so what we're looking at right here is
what's called a chart of accounts I'm
gonna just refer to these as income and
expense buckets but these are chart of
accounts a lot of these are going to be
pre-loaded in your accounting software I
will attach a PDF of this into this
program but I want you to take a good
look at the types so we've got income
you can call this income or client sales
or services that's going to be a revenue
type any kind of expenses such as
insurance or office supplies or rent
those are all going to be expenses so as
I said these will be already most of
these a lot some of them will be loaded
in your accounting software you can
change the names of them you can add
more to them but as you start to do that
use this as a guide as to what kind of
type what one put a name on it whatever
name you want and then you're going to
use the type of account it's going to be
and you can't put it you can put a
description in it's not
have to but this is very important
because this type is going to tie to all
your reports so depending on the type
that will tie to your whether it falls
on the P&L the profit and loss report
the balance sheet or the cash flow
statement most of the time they're
either going to just fall on the profit
and loss or the balance sheet so these
are general expenses this is revenue
let's go to this next page okay so right
here on owners contribution or owners
pay this is labeled as equity this type
is called equity and the reason for that
is because this is not an income event
so if you were to add money which would
be an owner's contribution add money
into your business account that would be
considered you're adding equity into
your account if you were to take money
out or to pay for any kind of personal
expenses from your business account I
don't recommend doing that on a daily
basis or on a regular basis but if you
made a slip up and you accidentally had
an Amazon account that got charged to
your business account but it was a
personal Amazon purchase you could take
that amount in code it to personal
expenses or owners pay um and those
would not be that would not be
considered an expense because your it's
the equity out of out of the money out
of your business account these others
right here some of these are kind of
accounts that are working in the
background so as you put in an invoice
that accounting software is
automatically going to code that invoice
under the type accounts receivable
because you're waiting for that money to
come in you're waiting for it to be
received to you Accounts Payable any
kind of bills you owe if you go in and
put a bill in but you haven't paid it
yet and this isn't a necessary way of
doing this you could certainly do it
that way it definitely helps with your
cash flow but if you're just paying your
expenses as they come that's fine too
but if you do decide to put your bills
in and then pay later that would be an
Accounts Payable
and that will be labeled as accounts
payable
that kind of automatically happens in
the background of your accounting system
if you have any loans that's going to be
a liability any taxes now taxes can be
both liability or an expense that's
something you probably need to talk to
your accountant to as far as how you're
managing your filing and when you're
filing your taxes that makes a big
difference any large pieces of equipment
are going to be considered assets and
then retained earnings so retained
earnings is any money that you made from
the previous year so let's say at the
end of your P&L you had a positive of
$10,000 on December 31st of 2018 so come
January 1st of 2019 that $10,000 is now
going to move into retained earnings and
now that P&L will essentially start at
zero so again use this as I guide I will
have a PDF of this and when you get into
your your accounting software you're
going to want to create these buckets or
name them and like I said a lot of them
will already be present but use this as
a guide to make sure you've got the
right type so then your reports are
correct as well okay I have a weekly
checklist a monthly checklist and a
quarterly checklist so weekly you want
to review your outstanding invoices and
make any follow-up calls as needed you
want to make sure you're organizing
receipts sort your bank transactions in
your within your accounting software
that's taking all those income and
expenses and sorting them into those
buckets we just talked about panty bills
and don't forget to pay yourself you
can't pay yourself monthly if you want
to do it that way weekly if you have a
good client flow it's not bad to pay
yourself weekly because it kind of just
helps you stay on track and helps you
know your cash flow a little better
monthly you want to reconcile your bank
and credit cards this is so important I
could create a whole nother video on
this I'm not going to but I suggest you
really look into doing this as
reconciling those making credit card
accounts against your bank statements
and your credit card statements this is
like a big double check of what's
going on within your accounting programs
review your profit and loss review your
income I'm sorry review your expenses
and subscriptions sub subscription creep
is real I've seen it a lot so make sure
you stay on top of those subscriptions
and you know what you're using and
ditching me the ones you are not using
and then after you review all that get a
good idea of your cash flow once you
kind of get a good grip of your expenses
you'll really start to know what your
cash flow situation will be like as well
as staying on top of those invoices any
overpaid invoices so quarterly you want
to make sure you pay your quarterly
taxes you want to review those pricing
structures and then another one that I
have not mentioned that's pretty
important is make sure all your clients
have a w-9 from you so any client that
you pay or I'm sorry that you invoice
over $600
they should be requesting a double nine
excuse me a w-9 from you if they do not
be prepared they may be requesting it
around mid to in January that's when we
have to file those w9 so keep that in
mind if on my next point if you ask for
any help or you get any 1099 contractors
to help you out you need to ask them for
a w9 and it's just a one sheet
IRS document that basically just says
you're an independent contractor you can
look it up google w9 and one of the
first two or three things to pop up in
google you need that as well and as if
you hire any 1099 contractors you need
to make sure you file those typically
it's the last week of January I'm not
going to be a specific date because the
dates change every year around the last
five days of January those need to be
filed they're very easy to file
it's 1099 filings is what they're called
so be prepared you're going to get asked
up from your clients and if you happen
to need to get any help with coding or
design work for a client that you're
working on you need to make sure they
hand you a w-9 is
all right that should wrap up your
checklist let's dive into the piano all
right you've made it we're not at our
last video so I'm going to talk about
the profit and loss on this one and
hopefully this will kind of wrap up
everything and help you understand why
it's important to do good financials and
really pay attention those income and
expense buckets okay so let's get
started okay so as you'll see on the
left there is a profit and loss example
of a profit and loss statement I have
blocked out the names and he dates
anything that could possibly reveal
whose profit and loss this is so let me
just start off with saying why you want
to run a profit and loss I think we all
want to do what we love doing and I'm
assuming you love being coders but I
also think we all need to know how much
money we're making and a profit and loss
is going to tell you that it's going to
take your income minus all your expenses
and then tell you what is left over and
the more you focus on this the more
you're gonna be able to realize what
changes you need to make maybe what kind
of pivots you need to make with pricing
maybe where you can cut back on expenses
where you could actually add more in
expenses so a profit loss is very
important in terms of giving you a
snapshot of where you are and you can
pull a profit and loss on a weekly basis
on a monthly basis quarterly yearly
it'll just tell you exactly how much
money you've brought in and how much
you've brought out this will help with
cash flow I'm not going to tell you this
is the best report I'm going to tell you
that a cash flow statement is a best
report for cash flow but for just
getting started this will give you an
idea at least on your expenses what you
could expect each month or even in each
week so this is why it's important to
have an accounting software that will
provide a profit and loss statement for
you I also suggest in terms of getting
overall health of your business and
trying to make business decisions just
is pulling a balance sheet and a cash
flow statement and if you don't
understand those to have someone help
you understand those and make decisions
moving forward anyway that's my soapbox
let's get started on the profit
so profit loss you're gonna have top
line is gonna be on your income you
might have different income types client
services client design work client code
work however you want to do that but
that is going to go back to those
revenue buckets so that's why back in
the other video when I talked about the
buckets that's what's forming this piano
in the background okay so you're gonna
see revenue slash income and expenses so
that's why that's important to make sure
those types back on the previous video
are correct so all of that information
lands on the right report okay so you've
got your income cost of goods and I'll
get to this in just a minute and then
your general business expenses so cost
of goods is going to be if you have any
kind of product that you have to
purchase and then you sell that product
to your client that is going to be your
cost of goods sold I don't think most of
you will incur any of this if you're
just doing service based business you're
producing websites and codes and apps
and things like that you really
shouldn't have any cost of goods but
that's just what that is here for so
you'll have top-line income cost of
goods and now you have a gross profit
and then from that gross profit these
are gonna be your general expenses your
rent your phone your internet your
insurance anything that you incur on a
regular basis or any kind of business
does it have your regular basis any kind
of business expense and then that at the
bottom that will give you your net
operating income so this is going to
tell you this 8090 $9.38 is going to
tell you how much money you brought in
in that given time period whatever given
time period you selected
okay so profit loss statement should
only have your business related expenses
income and expenses in terms of what it
should not have I'm gonna jump back to
that interest expense in just a minute
but I'll go ahead and I'll go ahead and
jump to the loan payment first so if you
have a loan a loan paper is a little
interesting in the fact that you have to
have you kind of have to split that
payment and you put the principal amount
to a liability account and the interest
amount can be on an expense account and
you can see that loan interest amount on
the profit and loss but the principal
amount is on the balance sheet and then
that's a little confusing if you have
any loans I would suggest getting help
setting that up once you get it set up
it's not that hard to manage but that's
just something that I see a lot of
mistakes made so bottom line is don't
put the entire loan amount on the profit
and loss statement it is not an expense
it's kind of a mix of an expense and a
liability I'll leave it at that for now
I don't wanna get too far in the leads
with that profit loss should not have
your owners pay so again this goes back
to that previous video about how the
owners pay is equity anything equity
related will be on a balance sheet so if
you want to pull up your running owners
pay out or running owners contribution
you will find that on your balance sheet
as long as it's code it to equity
mileage is not on a piano I get that
question asked quite a bit you can't
really put that on a profit and loss you
can track it I would suggest using my IQ
but you cannot really put it on them on
a profit loss so if you have mileage if
you are running from client to client
track that mileage and turn that into
your tax accountant and then bottom line
is any expenses that you do not feel
confident in justifying to the IRS
should not be on your profit and loss
period so if you I get a lot of clients
I've tried to want to put their kids
soccer club in their business they want
to expense that out because I want to
call it networking or they want to put
their Botox so they want to put every
Amazon charge they've ever had to their
profit and loss and label it as office
expenses I'm never gonna tell clients
what to do but I will tell you this is
you always want to feel confident and if
you were to ever to face an audit which
I ever hope you do not have to do but if
you ever have to face not it that you
can comfortably and confidently say that
it was a business expense here's my
receipt and here's my own voice so just
keep that in the back of your mind if
you ever
in question on I don't know if it's a
businessman so I don't know if it's
personal I don't know how to code this
just keep that in the back your mind and
then one other item that depending on
how you have your book set up is any
kind of what they call bad debt so if
you have any lingering invoices let's
say they're six months old or all or a
year or even more that you have not
gotten paid on you know you're not going
to get payment on I would bring that up
to you're a tax accountant when you go
to do taxes that may affect your taxes a
little bit for the better it may not it
really depends on how you have your book
set up so I didn't really want to list
that on there because it can be
different for everyone's situation in
terms of how their accounting sets is
set up that really gets into a cruel
basis versus cash basis I don't want to
get too far into that because
everybody's going to be different but
just keep that in mind keep track of
those and just if you do have any
lingering invoices bring that up for
your tax accountant and just let them
know and see if they have any
suggestions all right well I really hope
this helped you all please reach out if
you have questions get training if
you're not sure on what you're doing I
know it's a lot but if you just start
off on the right foot and you start
these good habits it'll make your life
so much easier and you will save money
in the long run and you'll be that much
more ahead of the game because you're
gonna know where you stand financially
what decisions you can make how you can
start to price where you can cut back
and how you can grow so stay in tuned of
your finances and don't be afraid to
reach out get help do a little bit of
research I have more information on my
website at KPI bookkeeping dot-com I've
got some blogs some videos so best of
luck to you and take care and thanks for
watching okay a big thanks to Aaron now
let's talk about how to manage your debt
work on a day to day basis
okay so it's time to start talking about
how you're going to manage your
substantive work on a day to day basis
and by substantive work I mean the
actual dev work which is the whole
reason you started free code camp and
got into being a developer in the first
place and managing your dev work
appropriately daily will allow you to
maximize your profits and proper
management of your day-to-day activities
really focuses on two things first is
the fact that you have to put in the
time in other words you know you have to
put the time into your business you have
to go to work you would be surprised at
how many entrepreneurs don't even put in
a 40-hour workweek and the second thing
is you have to make sure you're working
efficiently and why do I say that both
of these are important putting in the
time and working efficiently think of it
like this suppose you go to work and I
go to work and you're 25% more efficient
than I am and you work 30 hours a week
and I work 40 hours a week well if
you're 25% more efficient than me than
in 30 hours a week you will accomplish
what takes me thirty seven and a half
hours but because I went to work for 40
hours in the week I'm going to
accomplish more than you and because I'm
going to accomplish more than you I'm
going to make more money so with that
being said if you and I both go to work
for 40 hours and you're 25% more
important or efficient than I am then in
40 hours you will accomplish what takes
me 50 hours so this is why if you can
work efficiently and put in the time you
will make an astronomical amount of
profits compared to what you would make
otherwise now I think it's important to
stress these things because you would be
surprised at how many people don't put
in 40 hours a week into their business
so just as an example if you're going to
work and you're not you know keeping
track of your time which a lot of
self-employed people don't it can be
easy to feel like oh man I worked a lot
today when again at the end of the day
you're really not putting in as much
time as you thought you did right so
making sure you're putting in the time
and tracking the time
is rule number one so let's start by
looking at that and then let's look at
what you need to do in terms of making
sure you're working efficiently it will
give some tips for improved efficiency
okay so the first part of being
on a day-to-day basis is putting in the
time when it comes to your business
and putting in the time means that
you've got a certain number of hours
that you're going to work and that is
just gonna be a minimum that you're
gonna work every week there may be some
weeks where you have to work more right
because you may have a deadline you have
to meet a project may be taking longer
than expected you have to work over to
meet that deadline or something of that
nature but the crucial part is to pick a
number of hours you are going to work
every week and make sure you put in
those hours so in other words let's say
you're decide you're gonna work 40 hours
a week at your business you get all your
development work done and let's just say
30 hours then that means you've got 10
hours left that you need to be devoting
the marketing your business you know
that's you use that extra 10 hours to
write blog posts make youtube videos go
to networking events things of that
nature so again set a number of hours
that you're going to work every week and
make sure you are putting in those hours
and there is always something for you to
be doing so there's our what there are
ways for you to make sure you meet those
hours me personally in my business I put
in a minimum of forty three point three
hours every week and when I tell people
that number sometimes I get weird looks
because forty three point three is
obviously not a round number where I
came up with that is the fact that by
working in extra three point three hours
per week I wind up accomplishing in
twelve months what would take someone
working 40 hours a week 13 months in
other words three point three hours more
week adds one more working month to my
year and I find that combining that with
trying to work efficiently really
increases the amount I produce over a
year over the course of a year I should
say and as a result my income goes up so
pick a number that you're going to put
into your business and make sure you
stick with it again if you don't have
worked if you don't have development
work to do put that extra time into
marketing your business now it's really
important that you do this in a way so
that you avoid burnout let's say you
decide you're going to work 45 hours in
a week you know on average okay
and then let's say you have a week where
you work 47 well that means you can go
ahead and take off two hours in another
week and still be averaging 45 so in
other words when I say I work for you
3.3 hours a week over the course of a
year I make sure I average forty three
point three some weeks I might work more
some weeks I might work less if
deadlines make me work more one week the
next week I might take some time off or
things of that sort
so pick a number and stick with it
and make sure that you put the time into
something trust me there will always be
something you can be doing in your
business I cannot begin to tell you how
many entrepreneurs I see who don't don't
essentially know how much they work in a
week like if you were to ask them how
many hours do you require that you work
in a week they don't have a number which
I can understand someone saying they
don't know how many hours they work in a
week as a required number but then they
also don't have for example set times of
when they start work in the morning they
don't have set times of when they go
home they don't have set vacation
schedules or requirements or anything
like that
so think of it like this those
entrepreneurs don't get to work at any
particular time just they just get to
work whenever they feel like it they
leave whenever they feel like it
at the end of the week they're not
making sure they've worked a certain
number of hours and they just take
vacation time whenever they want and
people wonder why so many small
businesses fail well one of the reasons
why so many small businesses fail is
just to be frank people who start up
their own business don't put in the time
so pick a number of hours stick with it
and then make sure you're meeting those
requirements and if you do that this may
sound really simple but you will be
ahead of a lot of your competition
because your competition is just not
going to put into time it's just not
going to happen put in the time for your
business and you increase your chances
of success just exponentially I can't
stress that enough
if you fail there's a pretty good chance
that's because you weren't putting in a
time so again if we're gonna make a full
time if you've decided to make
your new development business a
full-time job my suggestion is actually
put your our requirement a little bit
over 40 hours because 40 hours is
considered a normal work week right so
challenge yourself a little bit do a
little bit more again I get an extra
month a year only by doing an extra
three point three hours a week if you
say three point three hours a week
sounds like a lot ask yourself how much
time do you spend looking at Facebook
how much time you spend you know
watching television I mean how much time
do you spend you know engaging in other
you know like idle activities just cut
out a few of those things and make sure
you're putting the time into growing
your business and then if when you
combine those hours with high efficiency
you'll produce so much that so many
people are gonna look at you and go how
did that person produce all that they
just want to understand it and they and
you will understand it was a function of
the time you put in plus the efficiency
so pick a number of hours and stick with
it and hold yourself to it show some
discipline you know get your work ethic
and and put put in that work ethic and
you will succeed so with all that being
said now let's take a dive into how you
can actually make sure that those hours
you're going to be working are going to
be spent doing something efficient
okay in our last segment we talked about
the need to put in the hours when it
comes to your freelance business but now
let's talk about how you can be
productive when you're putting in those
hours it's I'm gonna talk about this
because it's really important to
remember that putting in time it does
not necessarily equal getting stuff done
I've seen plenty of situations where
someone might actually spend literally
14 15 16 hours a day at work and leave
the day leave at the end of the day
accomplishing virtually nothing I
actually know of entrepreneurs who and I
feel bad for them literally work 16
hours a day probably 6 to 7 days a week
and are just so inefficient in terms of
how they go about their day that they
accomplish probably what an efficient
person would accomplish in a thirty hour
work week so if you take putting in the
time and combine it with efficiency
that's how you become productive and
that's how you make more money so the
thing I can't stress to you enough again
is you gotta put it in the time don't
think simply because you're putting in
the time that you're being productive
you have to put in the time but you also
have to be efficient in your use of that
time in other words you need to produce
a lot per hour so think of it like this
let's say you put in a lot of time let's
say you put in 50 hours a week and now
let's say you're twice as productive as
somebody else that means in other words
that you get twice done in an hour what
someone else gets done in an hour which
there are people that inefficient so
there will be people that you're
doubling their productivity if you put
in 50 hours you're twice as productive
of somebody else they have to go to work
for a hundred hours to you know
accomplish you know what you did in 50
and if they're only working a 40-hour
workweek takes them two and a half weeks
to accomplish what you accomplished in
one workweek and that's how you make a
lot more money you know as a freelancer
or as a self-employed developer so again
just simply going to work does not mean
you're getting stuff done you have to be
efficient in your use of time so let's
look at a few pointers and again these
are just a few it this is by no means an
exhaustive list let's look at a few
examples and
terms of how you can be more efficient
with the use of your time number one is
what I call the Ohio method Ohi o stands
for only handle at once I'll talk about
what this means in a minute
number two focus on completing one thing
at a time don't always have nine
different projects that you're trying to
complete simultaneously number three
when problems come up deal with them
immediately and number four is going to
be improved management of communications
and by this I mean things like email
text messages so on and so forth
if nothing else if you've nailed those
four areas you will be working so much
more efficiently than so many people out
there that at the end of the work week
people will just wonder how you got so
much done and the answer to how you got
so much done will be you didn't let time
just waste away too and get lost in
efficiency all right so let's look at
each of the things I just mentioned in
term number one the Ohio method Ohi oh
the stands for only handle at once and
this concept applies to anything whether
it's an email whether it's a piece of
paper sitting on your desk you know an
issue that comes up or anything don't
deal with issues more than once so think
of it like this a piece of paper comes
in you open it open up the letter it's
something from the Secretary of State
saying you've got to file something to
renew your business license well don't
just set it over here because as soon as
you do that now then that when you
decide to deal with it later you've got
to pick it up and read it again which
means you took the time to read it when
you first opened it and you need to hook
the time to read it when you deal with
it the second time so you're reading the
thing twice instead of once right so
when as soon as you pick up a piece of
paper deal with it in the under that
scenario envelope comes in I open it I
read it it's from the Secretary of
State's office saying hey you've got to
renew your business license I'm
immediately gonna put this down I'm
going to go online I'm gonna renew my
business license it's done I only touch
that piece of paper once in other words
I only handled it once think of how many
times in your life have you opened an
email read the email
and then said I'll deal with this later
right well then when you go to deal with
it later you have to read the email
again which again you just read the
email twice so imagine if you could cut
your time spent reading email in half
right
so only handle it once applies to
anything from a piece of administrative
paperwork to emails to you name it
anything that comes across your desk
only handle it one time now this can be
something that can be like very for lack
of a better word difficult for people to
implement because it's really easy for
something to come in and you look at it
and go I don't have time to deal with
this and you said it over here then you
don't have time to deal the next thing
is said it over here
you don't have time to deal if the next
thing then like you said it over here
and then you go to work on something and
you work all day and like you finish
that okay but then later on when you
look at these again I don't have time to
deal with this so you move it back over
here next thing you know you've just
moves the same pile of papers back and
forth five times and think of all that
time you've wasted and you felt busy but
all you were doing was moving those
papers back and forth which is again a
massive massive waste of time so you've
got to be disciplined in the sense that
you're not going to pick something up
unless you're prepared to deal with it
and then when you do deal with it or I
should say when you do pick it up you do
deal with it that's something again it
can be easy to go I don't have time for
this you don't have time not to do
things that way your time is so precious
you have to get things handled once and
only once okay so follow the Ohio method
that's rule number one only handle it
once rule number two is focus on one
thing at a time and by this I'm talking
about in your development work you need
to have one project finish it move on to
the next project finish it move on to
the next project finish it so like with
us for example like let's say we've got
I'm making up a number let's say we've
got four clients we're building websites
for you know I don't work on client
number one a little bit one day work on
client number two a little bit that day
same day work on client three a little
bit because all you've ever got that way
is a little bit of each thing done and
the reason that's bad is
it requires a lot of mental energy to
switch from one project to the next to
the next and so you're constantly like
getting an efficiency drain by switching
projects like that instead what we do
let's say we have four websites we're
working on we finished the first one
that we work on it we finish it done out
the door
then we work on the second one finish it
out the door third one finish it out the
door so on so forth and if somebody
calls and wants a project we tell them
okay you're number five in line and we
adjust the delivery date accordingly
when they ask when can we have it by we
give them an honest delivery date
because we say we've got four people
ahead of you you know just to give an
example so don't jump from project to
project as you get busy you're going to
have two three four and more projects
under contract that you know you're
gonna be working on get one done then
move on to the next one get it done then
move on to the next one get it done and
so on and so on and so on and if you've
got a bunch of projects already lined up
to do and somebody calls you wanting
more work be honest with them about a
delivery date say I've got this many
ahead of you in here here's what comes
next alright so one thing at a time and
it again saves you all that mental
energy of switching from project to
project a project which is just a huge
efficiency drain at the end of the day
number three when problems come up deal
with them immediately and here's what I
mean by this is it's really easy for you
know some for something to come up and
then for you to say okay I'll deal with
this a little later well if it's a
problem and you put it off till later
the problem only gets bigger the problem
compounds so now it becomes a bigger
issue to deal with and it can become a
bigger issue to deal with in terms of
money it can become a bigger issue to
deal with
in terms of time it can become a bigger
issue to deal with in terms of you know
other things so let me let me give you
an example the easy example I like to
use something comes in from the
Secretary of State saying you've got to
send a piece of paper in to renew your
business license
and things fall through the cracks and
it doesn't get done so now you're late
sending in your business license you get
a notice from the Secretary of State
saying you know you are now gonna have
to pay next four hundred dollars for
your business license that's a problem a
problem has just arisen you now have to
get your business license renewed and
there's an extra amount associated with
it by dealing with things as soon as you
get them then BAM they're taken care of
right you know if you get an unhappy
customer get them on the phone right
away get it dealt with you're like right
away if you see things in your business
that seem like they're causing an
efficiency eliminate them on the spot
don't say oh man we really gotta clean
up that process no eliminate them right
there on the spot don't let them cost
you more time as things go on when
problems come up get them dealt with and
get them dealt with on the spot I cannot
stress that enough
number four is your management of
communications and this is a big one
communications are one of the biggest
things that can make you feel busy even
though you're not actually producing
anything all right so let's look at two
ways that you can manage your
communications in a way that will
greatly and I do mean greatly greatly
greatly increase your productivity all
right and the first thing you can do in
managing your communications is avoid
real-time communication platforms like
slack Google Hangouts and and things of
that nature where it's more of a chat
than it is you know like a formal
message it's really easy like on a
service like slack for example to
constantly see messages coming through
and then when someone gets a message
others are prompted to respond and so on
so forth and you wind up having a much
higher message volume than you would
through mediums such as email and the
thing is number one every time you get
one of those messages you become highly
distracted and if it gets hard to get
back to what you were doing and get into
a workflow and number two the
overwhelming majority of those messages
you're getting through a real-time
service such as slack aren't actionable
anyway they're just noise okay so you're
basically filling your day with noise
which makes you feel busy but again you
don't actually produce anything avoid
real-time communications altogether I
cannot stress that enough we do not use
them in our businesses we don't use
slack we don't use Google Hangouts we
don't use any of those things and on the
subject of communications manage your
email properly so and what I mean by
that is go through your email one to two
times a day or however often you feel is
appropriate but set aside set times that
you're gonna go through your email and
avoid your email during all other times
think of it like this you sit down you
open your inbox you get a message from a
client you respond to it
client responds back you respond to it
again client responds back you respond
again client responds back okay that's
three or four emails from the client you
had to read and that's three or four
responses you've had to write now we all
know a lot of people use email in a way
where as soon as a thought enters their
head they got to fire off an email to
somebody about it right if you say I'm
only going to go through my email once a
day and that's it so like let's say for
example you're gonna go through your
email at 3 in the afternoon from 3 to 4
you're clear your email when you get up
and/or get to work I should say in the
morning you've got one one email in your
inbox from Joe clients during the course
of the day Joe sends you three or four
more emails well now at you know three
or four in the afternoon when you're
gonna go through your email you can read
all four or five emails Joe sent you at
one time and then you can send them a
consolidated response to all of them
right so in other words you get to type
one response as opposed to typing three
or four or five individual responses
that becomes a huge time-saver and the
other thing is you actually have less
email to read by following that approach
because if Joe is gonna email you three
four or five times during the day anyway
if you're responding to each of those
then he's likely to respond to your
responses so you go from getting four or
five emails in a day from Jody getting
15 right so you greatly reduce
the number of emails you have to read by
going through your email once a day or
twice a day and but again leaving your
inbox closed at all other times or if
it's not gonna be closed at least not
responding so set aside set times that
you're gonna respond to email and then
go through it using the Ohio method
which we discussed a minute ago so if an
email asks you for something don't just
respond and say I'll get back to you on
that respond with what the email
actually asks for and only go through
that inbox once a day and you will be
surprised at how much less time you
spend then your competitors going
through email so let's put together
everything we just talked about let's
say your competitor does not follow the
only handle at once method which was
number one which means your competitors
that work 40 hours a week and they
probably spend 10 hours just moving the
same stack of paper back and forth like
we talked about right so number one they
don't follow the Ohio method so how much
time are they losing their number to
your competitors jumping between
projects all the time which means they
don't produce as much right so let's say
they lose you know an hour a day moving
the paper back and forth by not using
the Ohio method let's say they lose 30
minutes of productivity a day by jumping
from project to project now they've lost
an hour and a half of productivity you
know a day let's say they don't deal
problems immediately and as a result the
problems become more time-consuming
later let's add 15 minutes or up to an
hour and 45 minutes a day now let's
suppose that due to inefficient
communication practices which is what we
just talked about with real-time
communication services and email let's
say they lose another two hours a day in
an eight-hour day we've just lost
probably three to four hours three hours
45 minutes for you to call it three to
four hours to essentially inefficiency
so if you go to work for eight hours and
that person goes to work for eight hours
and they're losing let's say four hours
are their their their data inefficiency
and you're not you're going to produce
twice as much as they are in an
eight-hour day which means you're going
to make twice
much money as they do working the same
amount of hours now combine that with
the last section of our video where we
talked about the need to put in a few
extra hours and combined that extra
productivity with those extra hours and
actually know your income shoots through
the roof right so again time but also
productivity so focus on the tips we've
just talked about in this and you are
gonna be fine so and you will actually
see your income go up substantially well
this is gonna wrap up our course on how
to succeed as a freelance developer I
hope you found this helpful if you have
any questions you know please feel free
to contact me directly you can email me
message me through LinkedIn whatever
works best for you and thanks for
watching